[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that feeling of just knowing a game is
right for you
when you first lay eyes on it it's such
a great feeling
the thing that happens is you you start
to feel
the excitement just build up i'm
thinking about it all the time
even in my sleep inclusive
company
i play video games because i love
stories
experiencing worlds that you can't
experience as yourself
i guess video games allow me to be what
i can't
it's fiction but it's not and come home
log on to your pc and disappear into a
different world
i am a part of something bigger a part
of something
beautiful as an autistic person
video games give me a place where i
could be in a world that
made sense to me i will tell you that
all of my family play video games me and
my brothers
we would share the computer one hour at
a time
really enjoying playing video games with
my dad my children my little sister
that connection between video games
allowing us to converse with each other
added a lot to our relationship games
like the world of warcraft let me meet
people
that i probably never would have i can
honestly say
i i met some of my best friends through
playing games
we have this connection that allows us
to
share our joys to share our achievements
and share
our growth together every time i'm able
to achieve something i'm able to
make myself proud killing heroic black
hand back
in warlords of draenor was one of my
favorite memories i managed to find that
one hidden pylon
with my one mutualist we beat hardcore
inferno diablo i was able to hit gold in
competitive in overwatch
they had someone say oh i can't lose to
a girl uh and i beat that guy so i was
able to
slay this warlock as a little gnome holy
priest freaking out and screaming the
whole time
it drilling through my body was going
crazy
many years ago i was doing a quest in
terror forest
and a lovely little mage came up and
said would you like a hand they helped
me for the rest of the day
we've been married now for over a decade
those video games filled a void
they failed the friendships that i
didn't have there isn't a huge
lgbtqia plus community in my city
so when i was able to play a video game
i was able to start talking with people
who didn't really care i was a gay male
but video games
were my escape when i was a teenager my
dad was diagnosed with als
and i look to video games as a way to
escape from that sort of reality
everything happens for a reason and i'm
just glad video games were there for me
i'll never stop playing video games
there's no way i imagine myself
one day being an 80-year-old grandpa
gamer playing video games has shaped me
i don't think i would be who i am today
my passion my
interest my excitement they belong video
games opened for me the world
and because of that i'm forever thankful
and i can't wait to see what the next
generation holds
[Music]
welcome to blizzcon line a celebration
of 30 years of blizzard communities
and 30 years of blizzard games
30 years is so many years
and last year maybe felt like one of the
longest of all
but throughout the years of blizzard
entertainment from 1991 to today
many of us can associate certain games
with milestones in our lives maybe you
were a little kid
the first time you played the lost
vikings
or in high school when you first played
a diablo game
or maybe you met your partner while you
were playing world
of warcraft that's the awesome thing
about video games
they give us experiences that are
relevant to the times in our lives
and experiences that we carry forward
with us
games are here for us during good times
and they're here for us even when we
feel alone
or maybe uncertain games are coming home
familiar comfortable with a connection
and a sense of belonging and while many
of us spent
most of 2020 in our actual
real-life homes games became
even more of a place to get away to be
free from outside concerns
even if just for a little while so
this is pretty weird usually
when we start blizzcon the opening call
is my favorite warcraft faction the
alliance
or my favorite faction the horde i get
confused
usually i'd be speaking to 40 000 of you
in person
at the anaheim convention center and
millions of you
around the world and usually that would
be a perfect way to celebrate
but nothing about the last year has been
usual
the pandemic has been hard on everyone
and for many different reasons
but if there's one thing that the last
year has taught us it's that being apart
physically doesn't stop us from moving
forward
it doesn't stop us from connecting with
our player friends
around the world diving in
as warriors and heroes
and checking on each other as humans
it doesn't stop us from sharing our
latest
epic gaming story we're celebrating
those of others games
continue to unite us
now to be honest
i wasn't sure how well blizzard could
work from home
there are thousands of people all
needing to work together
in creating our universes games and
experiences
never has it felt more true that it
takes a blizzard
to make a blizzard gang and in 2020
it became clear that the magic of
creating a blizzard
isn't just tied to a physical location
it's tied to the people who work here
and i continue to be so proud
of each and every one of them thank you
blizzard
we create these games and pour
all of our energy and heart into them
but it is you
the blizzard community that brings them
to life
and that's why blizzcon line is a
celebration
of you the guild leaders healers
dps tanks innkeepers
zerg taran protoss
blackwatch shimada the heroes
of sanctuary and of the storm
these next few days are for you our
blizzard community
for world of warcraft we'll be showing
you
what's next for both shadowlands and
classic
i'm sure you're all burning in
anticipation for that one
hearthstone is getting back to its roots
in a major way
we can't wait to show you how
[Music]
we also have news for our diablo
community
some of you were able to dip your toes
into the depths of hell
in the diablo immortal technical alpha i
personally
i really enjoyed seeing players embrace
the multiplayer aspect of meeting in
town
we can't wait for more of you to get
your hands on it
so it's only the beginning of the year
and already there is
so much to look forward to even though
we can't yet be together in person
the overwatch league will be kicking
things off in spring
and we'll be watching closely to see if
the san francisco shot
can continue their championship run
world of warcraft esports is back with
the arena world championship
and mythic dungeon international already
in full swing
in shadowlands starcraft 2
and warcraft 3 esports are going strong
with our friends at the esl pro tour
and qualifiers are already underway
for the first online stop of the 2021
hearthstone masters tour with the first
event taking place
next month
but before we get too far ahead
let's take a look one last time
twin times were a little simpler
in the early 1990s the internet was a
baby
cd sales and finally eclipsed cassette
tapes
cassette tape it's a rectangle piece of
plastic
and there's a tape inside and music
would get recorded on and
sometimes you needed a pencil to wind it
make it tight
i know it sounds crazy we were all
playing video games
on super nintendo sega genesis dos
or mac pcs i personally was a master
of config sys and auto exec bat
so many simple things in simple times
if only we could relive them
the stage is set the green flag drops
but the carnage begins
holy torinos
what a collection
now we're talking
crank up the volume
[Music]
unbelievable
[Music]
yay
[Music]
the blizzard arcade collection featuring
the lost vikings
rock and roll racing and blackthorne
these
are ports of the games just as you
remember them
allowing you to relive the original
experience of all three
titles in 13 different languages
with a couple of quality of life
upgrades
as an example we include very modern
cutting-edge functionality that wasn't
available in the early 90s
both saving and loading of games and for
those of you who purchased
any blizzard digital anniversary bundle
via battlenet
you'll automatically receive the
blizzard arcade collection
on pc today
now you ready to hear about some other
video games
let's hear what's next for world of
warcraft
[Music]
hello everyone thanks for joining us
today
no matter where you are world of
warcraft unites us all
whether you're exploring the shadowlands
classic azeroth
or another part of the blizzard universe
i'm glad you could make it
because we've got a lot of good stuff to
show you
but first let's start with some covenant
pride
carrion take flight
night bay let the hunt begin
necrologs to war
been there let's party
the world has thrown a lot at us since
the last blizzcon
and the thing that's really kept
everyone going on the wow team
has been connecting with all of you the
bonds we forge with our guilds
and family and friends in wow
are powerful and real as wow enters its
16th year
and blizzard celebrates its 30th
anniversary
we're so grateful to have the most
dedicated and friendly communities
in gaming let's recap the events in
azeroth
in wow classic we fought an endless
battle for south shore
and tauren mill we banded together to
open the gates of encourage
and join forces to take down kel'thuzad
in his floating citadel of nexramus
in shadowlands we helped our covenant
recover from the anima drought
brought on by sire denathrius master of
the vin thier
and traitor to the pantheon of death
we survived the halls of tour gas and
crafted legendary gear in our efforts to
expel dinatherius
from his castle lair
but innocent souls are still wrongfully
being sent to the maw
they face an eternity of torment and
heroes like anduin
remain chained in its depths the jailer
continues to grow in power he's
preparing to break free from the maw
and complete his plan to unmake the
entire warcraft universe
and sylvanas you may be wondering what
she's been up to
all this time today we're excited to
unveil
our first major content update for
shadowlands
chains of domination
look around you what makes you believe
you're not just a weapon to achieve his
end
enough join our cause
or be made to serve
right now you hold all the power
make your choice sylvanas windrunner
despite all our efforts the mall
continues to grow what if denathrius's
treachery
is irreparable the premise is lost
and bastion cannot save the shadow lands
alone
none of this should have happened
perhaps the winter queen could
my archon a living soul
seeks an audience a mortal
a king
by all our measures one who has spent
his life
striving for justice
one who would give anything to serve
his people
[Music]
one whose heart is true
very well he may approach
step forward
my ascended have spoken of you
the king held captive in the mall
that prison could not hold me forever
why have you come to bastion
[Music]
you have a key that i need
you will release this soul
from your grasp no
he is bound to me just as you
would sought to buy your own
brother
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the vessel performed its part
flawlessly
three keys to fame
then they will see
death was never meant
to be chained
right that is so intense
i know you probably have a lot of
questions about what you just saw
and what it means for the next stage of
your shadowlands journey
later today my teammates ian and jeremy
will be telling you more about chains of
domination
in our shadowlands update please check
out
the world of warcraft channel to find
out more
next i'm excited to share our upcoming
world of warcraft charity pet program
we've heard a lot from our community
about how much they love these pets
and the opportunity to give to a good
cause along with ideas to make the
program
even better so during this upcoming
campaign
you'll be able to donate whatever amount
you wish to directly support
our chosen charity once donations reach
our goal
everyone playing world of warcraft will
get a pet for their collection
as a thank you whether you were able to
contribute personally
or not and to make this a fun challenge
if we reach a stretch goal everyone gets
a second pet too
and here they are the first pet
is bananas literally he was originally
available to his select few
back in burning crusade era so we're
excited to give everyone
a chance to adopt him and if we reach
our stretch goal
you'll also get daisy the sloth
she's an all-new pet who'll hang around
your neck when you need a hug
your donations during this campaign will
go to support
the medical humanitarian organization
doctors without borders
also known by their french name
minnesota son frontiere
or msf they're an amazing group doing
important work around the world we're
grateful to have
such a generous community and we hope
you'll help support
this worthy cause we'll be sharing the
details about the charity pet program
on the world of warcraft website soon
so we've talked quite a bit about
shadowlands
classic players now it's your turn it's
my pleasure to hand off to my teammate
holly longdale she's a long time wow
player
a veteran mmo developer and she's going
to tell us what's in store
for wow classic
hi everybody first i'd like to thank
all of you who have ever been part of
the wow community over the years
you know online worlds like wow have
been a huge part of our lives for
decades now
as a dedicated mmo fan and a developer
myself
i remember hearing that blizzard was
going to be making their own
mmo and i thought well i guess i'll
check out that beta
and sure we all call the game wow but
really wow i could not believe i got bit
by the mmo bug
again i was so excited to be able to
make a night elf hunter
and be like that famous dark elf ranger
from the books that i loved
i have to tell you azeroth was and still
is
a place i love to live since last year
i've had the great honor to work
alongside the wow classic team
to bring these nostalgic experiences
back to life
for long time fans and a whole new
generation of players
as a fan myself i've had so much fun in
wow
from the simple things like drive by
buffing or
making friends on that long haul from
teldrassil to ironforge
all the way to the absolutely staggering
like when i jumped blindly through the
dark portal
and was running through hellfire
peninsula heard this
terrifying noise and then saw the
fell reaver biggest roamer i had
ever seen and i was very glad i had
feign death in that moment
and that's the thing about wow these
stories and experiences we all
share keep us coming back time after
time
with that said i'm super excited to be
able to share with you
where our adventures are taking us
next
[Music]
you dare enter my realm
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
your foolishness has brought you to this
end
take my blood and choke on it death
to the outsiders i'll turn your world
upside down
[Music]
you are not just
brings back so many memories right like
exploring the fungal forests of zanger
marsh or
being awestruck at the chaotic magic
alive in netherstorm the draenei in
exodar
the blood elves in silver moon i love
playing them both
do you choose to enlist the aldor or the
scryers
in your quest to fight the legion and of
course we can't forget
gathering all your friends to fight
illidan at the top of the black temple
i can't wait to relive it all with you
since the team first set out
on their own quest to bring the original
wow back to life
we have learned a ton about what players
are expecting from this kind of
experience
we've also learned when to keep things
just as they were
and where we all might be open to some
changes
we're bringing all these lessons into
burning crusade classic
with our primary goal to bring back the
same feeling you had
when you faced the fel reaver for the
first time or
when you were digging through piles of
fel hound poop
of course we can't get this right
without you our incredible community
soon you'll be able to revisit outland
yourself when beta starts and
tell us what you think later all wow
classic players are going to be
presented with a meaningful choice
for each one of your beloved characters
do you want to move on into burning
crusade classic
or do you want to stay in the original
classic era
forever whatever you decide
you can do it all with your one wow
subscription
now i know i've thrown a lot at you but
don't worry
we'll be getting into the details in our
panel later today
so stick with us we'll make sure you
are prepared and now
we're going to hear what's coming up in
hearthstone
[Music]
greetings we're truly excited to share
with you everything that's coming to
hearthstone this year
but first let's take a quick look back
at the year
of the phoenix we added our first new
class
the demon hunter ventured into the
ruthless outlands
then we went to scholomance academy and
got to explore
dual class cards and their powerful
synergies
and with our third expansion of the year
we brought you hearthstone's biggest
update ever alongside the menacing old
gods
in madness at the dark moon fair we
launched a brand new game mode
duels that saw more than 10 million
matches on its first day
we also introduced our long-awaited
achievement system
and made a significant overhaul to the
rewards and progression within the game
now it's time to say farewell to the
year of the phoenix
and see what's in store for hearthstone
this year
welcome to the year of the griffin
over the last couple of years we've made
big changes to hearthstone
throughout the year of the griffin we
want to keep delivering
fun new experiences and make sure
that the tens of millions of you playing
hearthstone
are always excited to log in first up
we'll be giving the standard format its
biggest
shake-up ever with the launch of the
core set
later this year the corset replaces the
old basic and classic sets
with a collection of 235 cards
made up of some of the best from
throughout the years
as well as 29 awesome brand new cards
and the best thing about the corset is
that it's entirely free
so there's never been a better time
to get into hearthstone here are three
of hearthstone's legendary dragons
reimagined to feel more up-to-date and
competitive
for modern-day hearthstone yasera
the dreamer you'll finally receive her
full
arsenal of dream cards right away she's
a nightmare for your opponents
malygos the spellweaver he'll fill your
hand with spells
and is a powerful late game play
worthy of the aspect of magic
and finally everyone's favorite black
dragon
deathwing he's still as destructive as
ever
but timed correctly he won't leave you
empty-handed
we'll also be launching a brand new
format
classic where you can play hearthstone
as it was
when it first launched the classic
formal will be fully supported
complete with ranks and rewards using
hearthstone's original set of cards
so if you want to relive the old school
experience
then classic is the place for you with
classic revisiting the past
now let's take a look to the future and
explore the first expansion
of the year of the griffin
for a hero of the horde
all roads lead to the crossroads
you have come for adventure
but the barons wants to break you
must be mighty
this is who we are
that's right we're heading to one of
warcraft's most iconic locales
the barons and will come face to face
with the heroes that inhabit it
starting with one of the horde's most
iconic and well-known characters
a fierce loyalist one-time warchief that
embodies the honor
loyalty and spirituality of the horde
shadowhunter vol'jin shadowhunter vulgin
is a neutral legendary that allows you
to either bolster your own board
or weaken that of your opponents and
to celebrate the announcement of forged
in the barons this card
is available for free for everyone later
today
so log in to hearthstone and claim your
free copy of shadowhunter
vol'jin and as a bonus
we're also giving away the brand new 30
years of blizzard card back
next we have another hero of the horde
who is making his first appearance
in hearthstone the legendary blademaster
samuro featuring the new keyword
frenzy frenzy activates the first time a
minion takes down
and survives in samuro's case this can
be used
to clear your opponent's board heroes of
the horde
like samurai are famous for their combat
prowess
but others like thrall are known for
their powerful elemental magic
take a look at this new shaman spell
chain lightning
chain lightning is a spell in a new
cycle of cards
that rank up and become more powerful
when you have five
and ten mana ensuring that they're
always useful at every stage in the game
you'll also notice that they're
categorized as nature spells
with thoughts in the barons we'll be
permanently introducing spell schools
across the entire game which enables a
whole host of exciting
new strategies and don't worry members
of the alliance
will be featuring some of your most
beloved heroes
and locales later this year
but what i love most about the warcraft
universe
is its amazing characters and our final
announcement
is our most ambitious addition to
hearthstone yet it introduces a brand
new way to play
with your favorite heroes hearthstone
mercenaries mercenaries features
strategic rpg gameplay
where you build teams consisting of some
of the most iconic
heroes and villains from the warcraft
universe
including timeless characters like the
infamous sylvanas windrunner
and ragnaros the elemental lord of fire
you can also expect to see some of
hearthstone's fan favorites
like the unstoppable devil saw king
crush
and the ever-growing gruel the dragon
slayer
you'll lead them in battle through
highly replayable
rogue-like missions where the map is
randomly generated
every time you play and each node
represents a unique
challenge for your teams take on your
heroes gain levels
new abilities equipment and can even
evolve into
more powerful versions of themselves
we're thrilled to finally show you
hearthstone mercenaries
it is scheduled to launch later this
year and
we'll have more to share with you down
the road
everything you've seen today is just a
taste of what's coming in the year of
the griffin
so don't forget to tune in to our deep
dive panel after the opening ceremony
where we'll share more details on the
core set
the new classic format forged in the
barons and
our plans for battlegrounds and jewels
as well as
our upcoming single player content i
want to thank the team for their amazing
work and on behalf of all of us at
hearthstone
we want to thank the many millions of
you who play our game
your dedication and support is what
drives us to make
awesome updates and pursue ambitious and
fun
ideas we can't wait to kick off the year
of the griffin with all of you
and we hope to see you in the game soon
next up you'll get an update on all
things
diablo
hey everyone thank you very much for
joining us i am
so excited to kick off the diablo
segment
of our show and i am honored to be here
on behalf of all of our diablo teams
to share the news and updates we have in
store for you today
we've got a lot of diablo to cover and i
hope you'll agree with me that it's a
great time to be a member of this
community
all right let's kick things off with
diablo 4.
we first shared our game with you during
blizzcon of 2019
and we've been truly humbled by your
response we've kept in touch
through quarterly updates and sincerely
appreciate the thoughts
and valuable feedback you've provided as
we unveil
more and more of the game and share in
its development
after all diablo belongs to you as much
as it belongs to us
most recently we teased and updated to
our campfire screen
and savvy fans of course understood that
we meant
more than just the character lighting
and fire visual effects
that's right today we're happy to
announce a brave new soul
joining the barbarian the sorcerer and
the druid
on this dangerous journey back to
sanctuary
a class is one of the most exciting
things you can announce in a diablo game
this one is especially exciting to me as
it's a re-envisioning of one of the
first classes to ever appear in the
series
let's have a look
there is justice within the light
but you have to be patient
now pray with me
may akhanat guide and protect me
may akharat guide and protect me
may he shepherd my soul may he
shepherd my soul and grant it
mercy and granted
mercy what are you doing here
this is not the time but this
is confession
and i have sinned
i was a thief who stole from those more
fortunate
i strayed from your light
and found my trade in the shadows
they call it murder
i say job well
done
[Applause]
[Music]
i am a thief a heretic
a murderer father
will akara save me
hmm you mark our light
but those monsters were a scourge upon
my frog
and you
oh you were the answer to their prayers
then we are settled and you owe me
the name you seek is
thank the heavens for you
heavens i assure you father
[Music]
the heavens didn't send me
wow
wow
just the sound of that ear getting
pierced by the hook is so brutal i feel
like it's going to haunt me for a long
time
i've been a huge fan of the rogue ever
since the original diablo
even seeing them come back as npcs and
mercenaries in diablo 2's rogue
encampment
served as a great bridge between the
games
with the setting of diablo 4 being a
larger world than we've
ever played in before we're excited to
show you
not just what the successors to the
original rogues in the series
have been up to since the fall of their
order but also
what some of the other rogues in the
world of sanctuary might look like
the mantra for diablo 4 has been
customization
first and the rogue takes us to a whole
new level
from the beginning the rogue has been an
incredibly
flexible class able to adapt to any
situation
our goal is to let you create the kind
of road
that you want to play whether it's an
unrivaled archer modeled after the
original sisterhood
or a cloak and dagger road from the
darkest alleys of caldeum
in diablo 4 you will have the freedom
to create the rogue that you imagine by
customizing the looks
the background and the play style of
your character
please stick around for our segment
later today
where i'll be joined by other members of
the diablo 4 team
to share a closer look at the rogue
class as well as some of the open world
gameplay that we're bringing to the game
spoilers those severed ears are not just
for show
but diablo 4 is not the only diablo game
we're talking about today
if you're looking for an authentic
diablo experience
on mobile we've got you covered diablo
immortal has
everything you'd expect from a triple a
action rpg
from the visceral combat and epic loot
to an
all new story bridging the gap between
the events of diablo 2
and diablo 3. later today you can join
the immortal team
where they'll talk about some of the
things they've learned from their recent
alpha test and what's
next for the game but that's still not
all
we have one last bit of very exciting
diablo news to cover
when you hear us talk about the classes
the items or the stories
of the early diablo games you may have
picked up
on the absolute reverend tone we reserve
for that golden era of diablo
maybe you share that love of the
classics and just hearing us talk about
them
makes you want to take on mephisto or
bale one more time
or maybe even for the first time after
all
some of our favorite moments happened a
long time ago
and not just in sanctuary years
if so we have a special surprise for you
today
let's check it out
don't do it
[Music]
focused hour it may yet be
your greatest moment
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
not even them
after more than 20 years the dark
wanderer
has returned and once again he travels
east always east
diablo 2 is a landmark game for blizzard
diablo 2 resurrected is a full
hd remaster of both the original game
and the expansion lord of destruction
it takes the 2d sprite-based classic
that we love
and brings it into the present in 3d
utilizing up-to-date graphical rendering
and lighting technologies
it also includes modernizing all
27 minutes of cinematics
recreated shot for shot with the
explicit
intention of preserving both the look
and the pacing of the original movies
blizzard
has a long history of games that we're
proud of
and when we think about diablo 2 we
think about it
as a definitive pillar in our foundation
now it's funny to think that some of you
weren't even born when d2 was released
which
makes it all the more important that we
deliver an authentic experience
wherever you play we want everyone
to relive their memories or experience
the game for the very first time
on their platform of choice and so we're
excited
to bring diablo 2 resurrected to pc
and console along with cross progression
and for those of you who are in love
with the original
and you just wish it worked more
seamlessly on modern computers
you can bring back all of that nostalgia
exactly as you remember
and enjoy the game in its original
later today diablo speedrunner mr lama
will host a round table with members of
the development team
on the dedicated diablo channel if you
are a diablo 2 fan
i encourage you to take a look
so from diablo 2 resurrected
to burning crusade classic to the
blizzard arcade collection
it's a whole lot of looking back and
while we have teams
dedicated to bringing these timeless
experiences
into your hands it's actually a very
small percentage of our developers
working on these projects far more
people
are working on the future of blizzard
and in addition to what we'll be talking
about during the show
we can't wait to tell you even more
about our plans
over the course of this year and beyond
if you had asked us 30 years ago what
gaming would look like today
none of us could have predicted the
current blizzard lineup of games
the advances in technology are one thing
but it's really what those advances
have enabled that's even more incredible
if you think about the people who play
games
and the communities that have grown up
around them the way people
can connect instantly no matter where
they are in the world
the way people are increasingly able to
express
their identity and celebrate who
they are through their favorite games
communities
and platforms the explosion of things
like streaming
cosplay and esports it would have been
hard to imagine
any of that 30 years ago and at blizzard
that is what excites us about the next
30 years
there is so much that we're working on
and some of it you already know about
the rest
we look forward to talking to you about
it when the time is right
just like the real world the worlds of
warcraft
diablo starcraft heroes of the storm
overwatch and hearthstone are diverse
expansive and full of potential
we are not only iterating on the
experiences
that you've come to expect from us we're
also exploring
different ways to express our worlds and
welcome
more players from more places into them
and we aspire to continue to lead on
priorities
like accessibility and toxicity control
and to continue supporting causes that
have a positive impact
on the real world we want to continue to
bring
those same feelings of joy and
achievement
that we all felt when we first defeated
the lich king
we'll be diablo on hardcore mode
because when we get out on those
experiences with others
we can't help but see the similarities
between us
and feel what's possible when we play
together
of course there are new blizzard worlds
that we haven't visited quite yet
and when we do finally unveil those
games and experiences
our hope is that you will see in them
what we do
that no matter who you are or where
you're from
they are spaces where you can create new
stories
forge new friendships and make memories
worthy of lasting a lifetime
and through it all our mission statement
of being dedicated to creating the most
epic
entertainment experiences ever along
with our core values
led by gameplay first we'll continue to
guide our way
so on behalf of everyone at blizzard
thank you for being on this journey
for me personally it is the honor of my
professional life
to serve you and the honor of all of us
at blizzard
to be the caretakers of the worlds that
you play in
we are so excited for what's to come
this year
next year and the next 30 years
now what's coming next for the show
well it depends on where you watch
for those of you looking for an update
on overwatch
check out the behind the scenes look
into the development
of overwatch 2 over on their dedicated
channel
right after the conclusion of opening
ceremonies
there you'll hear about overwatch 2 new
content
new features including new maps hero
missions
talent trees and more of what we think
will make overwatch 2
a unique gameplay experience for world
of warcraft
diablo and hearthstone you'll get a
closer look
on their respective channels and on the
dedicated strategy channel
some starcraft legends will be going
head-to-head
in epic competition once again
welcome to blizzcon line be good to one
another
welcome home before we kick things off
here's a little something from a
previous blizzcon headliner
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm king of the world
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
uh
[Music]
your death
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
strike the greatest
you are not prepared
frostborn hungers for your soul
[Applause]
your time has come
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
strange
[Music]
[Laughter]
greetings to you seems you're ready for
the real thing
watch your back
piece of cake
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome everyone to our deep dive panel
for wow classic
i'd like to start with some
introductions with these fine gentlemen
with me and myself i'm holly longdale
i'm the principal producer for wow
classic
a little bit about my background i spent
13 years working on
everquest i started as a game designer
and eventually became
the head of the studio for the everquest
franchise
that said i've always been a wow player
since beta
so this is obviously a dream come true
for me and i'm thrilled to be here with
you
i'm patrick dawson um i'm the production
director for world of warcraft
i've been at blizzard for 15 years now
and have been on wow for most of that
time
um avid wow player myself and really
excited to open up that dark portal
again as we all step through it
and my name is brian birmingham and i'm
the lead software engineer on wow
classic
i've also been at blizzard for 15 years
i started on world of warcraft i spent
about three years on hearthstone as well
and then came back to the world of
warcraft team to work on wow classic and
it has been a great joy to me to work on
this team
there's a lot to talk about today yeah
so earlier we announced
yay burning crusade classic is coming
but there's a lot more to it
let's take a look at the features
because wow
i mean wow right
um i was so excited by playing dranai
and blood elves i played both uh and i i
will say my hearts with alliance
and i also took up jewel crafting on my
draenei
shaman i wanted to corner the market
just the whole notion of having items
with sockets and
just exploring that whole system i'm
also a bit of a systems nerd
so uh i i completely lost my time
for weeks in there burning crusade
i remember being there back then i mean
it was our first expansion ever
um so all the new features was was like
this really cool moment of like
what's coming next what's going to
happen uh and one of the things that
um you know was pretty impactful to the
game was horde having paladins and
alliance having shaman
i mean as an avid pvp or myself i
remember
going back and and trying to fight
shaman i was alliance back then
and just not understanding that class at
all because my team didn't have it so
like i try to polly them
and and then be like grounding totem i
didn't know what that was and it's just
like why are sean immune to everything i
don't know that's not what you said
yeah no but no i did no you said they're
cheating
i understood
but shaman why like now i started to
understand shaman a little bit better we
got some of their benefits
uh you know i actually like got to see
totems being placed down on my side for
once
uh i got to see the frustration of
dealing with bubble hearth on the other
um yeah i remember when i was doing
raids we were always jealous of the
alliance
having paladins for blessing of
salvation like people would be pulling
aggro off me and i'd be yelling at them
like wait for three sunders
[Laughter]
just like no it's no problem just you
know just go just go
so hey i mean you know we were upset
raiding like razor gore without
earthbind
i mean really even the playing field for
both pve and pvp which was just kind of
cool
but there were a ton of new features and
and disabilities with this too you know
as we as we got to level 70 and got to
experience new content new things
i remember one of my first experiences
with understanding what it meant but for
uh like
like designed by blizzard right yeah
because i was an engineer right i wasn't
a designer i was i was working on like
the live
the live ops team at the time and um you
know i
i was playing my class avid player magen
and i kept uh i sent this long email to
tom chilton
saying like hey um you know here's what
mage needs
dawson manifesto it's a well thought out
forum post
and what was in it was was things like
bring back a invisibility let's get a
threat
up in the class and i didn't even
necessarily tie those two together but
he was like that's a pretty good idea
let's give me
some visibility and and just knowing
that that skill was coming along with
some other new stuff from mages like the
armor or the ice lances was just really
cool to see all this new stuff
in bernie crusade on the other side of
that i i was really excited about spell
reflect because i was really frustrated
getting poly morphed and being able to
like reflect that back on the mage as of
course i was not excited
i bet you weren't and there were even
some pve encounters that uh
that had abilities that you could
reflect back so i remember that was a
lot really fun to kind of find ways to
time that and
use it as a defensive ability as well i
was a hunter mm-hmm
i'm 100 yeah i've switched um but i
remember just chasing beastmaster and
just dps dvs
that was it that was the chase yeah
talking about that too makes me think of
like the arenas in the arena system
that was a whole new world for for us
you know with battlegrounds in the way
they worked before like
the way the matchmaking happened usually
i was pretty competitive in pvp so
i would either get in there and stop the
enemy team it was just there to be
casual
or you know even though like we were a
good team we weren't like the best of
the best so when we ended up going
against one of those teams
it was just like well geez we're just
getting stopped now this is
this is tough uh arenas gave everyone an
opportunity to
play against equal minded opponents
right so if you were a little bit more
casual
you get the opportunity to play against
people who weren't maybe so competitive
or if you were like cutting edge go for
it like try to be the best of the best
um and what was great about that is it
really just it spawned in esport
like that wasn't yeah we didn't design
it for that we just wanted people to
have fun
uh but when we noticed like hey
everybody's playing this everybody's
like
competing in this people are watching it
we had to embrace that we started
featuring
blizzcons and we've been doing it every
year since yeah it's really awesome
i think one of my favorite things to
recollect was the exciting zones that
you would travel through
one of my favorite memories was actually
in the the first zone hellfire peninsula
and it was uh adventuring around at
hellfire peninsula
going around and doing all those quests
and always living in fear of the fel
reaper
because you'd be out there collecting
parts from like a broken zeppelin
and you'd uh and you'd be fighting off
your hellboards and then all of a sudden
you'd see the screen start to shake and
like these thump thump thump and then
you're like oh my god i gotta run he's
right on top of me sound still haunts my
dreams oh
no yeah it's terrifying even in life
it's just fain death
and then the payoff when you later go to
another storm
and they give you the quest they're like
could you get me apart from inside the
fellow even you're going to have to kill
him
and you're like that guy like that guy
that used to terrorize me they're like
yeah i think you could take him now
that was just that was such an exciting
payoff to be able to like uh bring that
full circle and go back and
see him again for me uh i snuck into
beta
i got really lucky because i i could see
the construction sign for some of the
zones and of course i ignored it
and went and explored so i remember
running through
blade's edge and just seeing dragon
carcasses and skeletons
impaled in the environment and then
moving on to another storm
i just was blown away even from zanger
marsh all the way through
everything felt like its own world and
just be able to go through that
and just the delight of it and the
epicness of it and then you
come up to area 52. that's what i love
about wow is you can have epic epic
story lines and still find lightness in
it so
i just loved it i love i'm an explorer
so you know for me
i remember bernie crusade really opened
up a new
gameplay type for me i i became a
collector and crusade
right and it kind of started with the uh
the outdoor inspire rep
because because i got my outer rep all
the way up and then i was thinking about
switching to scryer and people were like
you're insane you don't you know don't
do that
uh and i was like i bet i can you know
just
and i did and it was cool it was really
fun but then but then i started doing
other things like there were all these
new like mounts and pets and
and i went back and even got some of the
older raps like thorium brotherhood in
winter spring
um but then like things like nether wing
ledge came out the world just opened up
for me in bernie crusade to really start
my collection
of course we also had flying mounts
which i loved
and then decided to play with some
friends on a pvp server
and was running around hellfire and
death from above which is likely just
pat
probably yeah you were flying around
harassing people pat
i was getting a lot of honorable kills
[Laughter]
so that's just a quick look at some of
our memories for
burning crusade and that was 13 years
ago
so that code has been hanging around for
13 years
and we're not just doing a save as
burning crusade classic
oh no it's a lot harder than that so
let's get into some of those details
so one of the challenges has been uh
that we don't actually want to ship on
the old code
and the reason for that is because it is
uh it's got a lot of bugs and
uh and difficulties with the
architecture that we don't wanna we
don't wanna have to deal with but we do
want that old data and we talked about
this when we did the original launch of
classic
was how the data is really the thing
that describes how the game is supposed
to be played and what things are
supposed to happen in it
and so we want to bring that old data
and we want to run it on the modern code
the same as we did for classic
and there's like 750 000 rows of data
that we have to go through and convert
from their old formats to their new
formats
and uh fortunately we have really
talented engineers and uh we run
automated scripts that go through this
but even after we've run these scripts
we have to compare them with you know
with how it used to behave and make sure
that we've actually done the conversion
correctly
and then there's even some things that
are making it more difficult this time
like the fact that we've made a couple
of minor changes or bug fixes in the
classic data
and uh and we want to make sure that we
keep those as we're going into burning
crusade so we have to merge those
changes
with the changes that happened with the
burning crusade originally and make sure
that we have a coherent set of of
changes that
that make sense to bring us from classic
into the party crusade
there's an enormous amount of time spent
looking at okay this is how it came out
now
we have a reference client yeah that is
the original that's right we actually we
do use the old code for that so like we
still have it we just don't want to ship
on that anymore but we have like the old
code with the old data
knows exactly how it's supposed to
behave so those things work together and
we can bring that up internally and take
a look at it and say like okay this is
how it
how it was back then this is exactly
what it used to look like and we do
sometimes find things that
are bugs we still want to fix but a lot
of times it will tell us like oh this
thing is not a bug this is actually the
intended behavior or this is something
we don't really remember right there's a
tendency to to want to chase your own
memory like i remember it being like
this
and it's like no it's it's not always
exactly the way you remember it
everybody has that kind of human failing
even us and so a lot of times we'll have
have an argument but i remember it this
way well i remember it this way let's go
and check we can look
but you know another reason to ship on
on the new code uh is really just the
the years of stability
improvements and the fact that the world
didn't look the same back in 2007 as it
does today
that's true there wasn't cloud
architecture at that point um i remember
i
had the privilege of being on the on on
that live ops team where i got to see
what all the servers looked like and how
it was all architected
and to pull back the curtain on this a
bit the way it was is everything was its
own
own like server right like they didn't
really talk to each other very well
so each uh each realm had 11 blades on
it
and these blades were just bare metal
blades and like one blade was for
azeroth one blade was for kalimdor one
was for outland
and then we had some for instances and
you know back then what would happen
without cloud is you would try to
request resources and maybe
a lot of people were running dungeons
and so it would give you back things
like transfer reported instances not
found
oh boy like we don't want to go back to
those days so now we have we can take
advantage of things like the cloud
and not have those resource issues so so
shipping on this new code is a big
improvement in stability yeah and so
we're basically
we're weaving all these threads together
we did finally get a build for a burning
crusade classic
super excited uh with the team gets
together we're preparing for a play test
and we go to create our characters
and we see uh this blood elf who
you know he remembers the sun well he
forgot his pants
yeah so everything didn't work the first
time
what i know yeah i did mention like uh
we had to go
check for problems in those conversion
scripts so yeah
sure sure enough uh what's going on here
is uh is that this guy thinks he's
dressed but he isn't
and you can see why he thinks he's
dressed if you like does that happen to
you a lot
only in my high school dreams you can
see that
if you look at his calves you can see
that he's got the they're flared out
because he thinks he's wearing boots
and what the way this system works is we
uh we first set the geometry up for all
the items that you're supposed to be
wearing
and then we layer on various images that
we call textures
and we'd use those to build up a single
composite texture that's then wrapped
around the geometry
but of course in this case when we were
layering them on none of the textures
were assigned
so it just started with his uh you know
naked body
and then was going to go layer on
textures and didn't find any so it
thinks he's dressed and so it's removed
the underwear because it thinks it's put
clothes on top but there aren't anything
there they're all just completely
transparent
so it's almost like the emperor's new
clothes he's wearing invisible clothes
only in this case that's really what's
happening
that's crazy um and then of course i
wanted to try dranai
because that's where my heart lies i'm
an alliance girl
and uh this draenei looks to be uh heads
above the rest
that's not the exodar yeah yeah
definitely not done
right it is and that's exactly the
problem it looks like the drain is too
tall but the real problem is that we're
in the wrong place
and so yeah when you uh when you go to
the dunmorow character select screen of
course the camera is positioned for uh
much shorter races like gnomes and
dwarves
and so it's about knee-high on a train
and then water really brian we have
water and hellfire
yeah so it turns out that uh outland has
a funny uh
unique feature that it doesn't have any
oceans because the water just all
falls off the edges and goes out into
space or something like that i'm not
sure how that
works in uh in the game universe but
yeah
there's no ocean there but we had
accidentally flagged it to generate
ocean so we ended up flooding the entire
world with an ocean until we
found that and turned it back off so
through all of these processes yes we're
obviously
uh we're fixing what is broken um
but also we we thought it was a good
time to start
uh enacting what we call hashtag some
changes
to to gameplay and and how uh things
should work yeah i mean
when you think about it like classic our
guiding principle was no changes the
goal was to provide
as true to life a thin experience of
classic that we possibly could for the
community
um and we we accomplished that what was
interesting to me is to see this this
vibrant community that embraced it and
then said
hey uh but we're not exactly the same as
we were
15 years ago right and they're right
like the the times have changed the
world has changed
um and so some of those things that
maybe were out there that were
not great and were warts back in the day
is not something that we would want to
ship again like something that is feels
a little buggy or wrong or incorrect so
the idea behind this is let's provide
what the bernie crusade experience was
without those warts this really i think
illustrates the the
uh the difference is spell batching
we actually had a lot of requests
originally for spell batching in that
kind of no
changes charge where they said hey i
remember when i used to be able to have
two mages polymorph one another and they
would both end up polymorphed and that's
cute and fun and i kind of like that and
so we said okay well we can put that
back in
but the system that causes that is of
course that the spells are batched up
and and processed in these you know
giant batches
but over the last two years people
realize that what that comes with is
about a half a second
of uh of kind of built-in latency where
you push a button and
it doesn't actually take effect for for
that half a second while it's waiting to
queue up the other ones to go with it
and people were starting to find that
frustrating
i talked to a lot of people who said
they were excited about it when it first
came out with classic but
after they've been playing with it for
two years they're really ready to see it
go and we're ready to take it out too so
we're going to remove spell batching
with bernie crusade that's that's
definitely great because i remember like
every two weeks i get a book report
vanish is broken again
and it was because of stuff like this
right like if you vanished at the same
time a fireball is hitting you yeah it's
gonna pop you out right exactly
and so we were trying to do all these
tacky solutions to it but the real
answer is just
don't don't spell batch yeah um but we
didn't have the ability to do that then
so
glad we're doing it now yeah you know
another one that i can think of is um
just
how the rating community is matured
right like things were very different
um back in in 2004 2005 timelines
uh compared to today so um you know the
rating
community knows exactly what's going on
and they want to challenge they want
more of a challenge so
you know rather than always giving them
like the last version of the boss the
final form of the boss which maybe is
been hit with a few nerfs uh let's not
do that anymore let's give them a more
uh challenging version of the boss i'll
give you an example of like
muru right where the initial version
that boss had a lot of spell pushback
and so like that made it really tough to
bring casting classes to that
fight uh we did fix that pretty quickly
and and and and
change the fight to allow for that now
that's a change we probably would
incorporate
in this right like we don't want people
to feel excluded or not part of
being able to do to do a fight like that
but then probably a month or so after
that we nerfed movers health
um that doesn't need to happen let's
just let's just keep it in the hard form
we can evaluate any changes we need to
make after that but uh yeah we'll just
be like hey final form we're not even
going to look at it
let's call it a day yeah so how how did
your mage handle the pushback
uh i jus i just feels personal
[Laughter]
i was the raid leader so the one mage
allowed to go that was
honestly that's one of my favorite
fights every world of warcraft that was
a really really fun fight that's awesome
another change that we're talking about
making is along the lines of that uh
pvp balance and faction balance is uh we
know
obviously with burning crusade paladins
are introduced to the horde
and shamans are introduced to the
alliance and that was intended to be
a balancing of the factions and let's
you know make them even
and then they wanted to kind of keep a
little bit of flavor of that faction
identity
so they kept the seal of blood on the
horde and seal of vengeance on the
alliance
it was intended to be equivalent power
abilities that were just slightly
different in flavor
but in retrospect seal of blood was just
so much better and so one of the changes
that we are going to make is we are
going to give
the opposite factions seal to the other
faction uh but we're going to do that at
max level so we keep just a little bit
of that faction identity where horde
will get sealed blood at level 64
on schedule and then get seal of
vengeance at level 70 and similarly
alliance will get seal of vengeance at
level 64
and then their equivalent seal of the
martyr at level 70. another thing we
want to talk about is uh arena teams
when it first came out in uh in burning
crusade the arena team system
only let you have the same number of
players on your team that was the size
of the bracket it was for
so for example a 3v3 team can only have
three players on the team
so if someone was like sick or
unavailable one night you couldn't play
and that felt really frustrating so
we're definitely going to go with like
the last version of that where
you could have twice the size of the
bracket on your team roster
so that you had alternates you could
swap in and out and uh and then that way
as long as anybody had participated in i
think 30 of the matches
then they got the full credit for the
week of participation is that when we
did personal readings versus team
ratings
i think that came later and we're also
considering whether or not we want to do
something with that as well
because another thing that was
problematic about uh arenas
was the way that the elo system was so
inflationary and so we're talking about
whether or not we want to move forward
with uh with converting that to
something more like the modern mmr
system so that it isn't
isn't as punishing to people in terms of
like waiting hours for a match
at the highest levels and things like
that and another change
we we're going to give players access to
blood elf and draenei early so that
before we actually
open the dark portals you'll have a
chance to level those up that's
definitely not something we did
originally
yeah i remember i had a friend who was
really frustrated that the rest of us
were all running around in outland and
he was like i'm still
like wetlands yeah what is going on
yeah when can i play with you guys so
yeah i'm really glad we're doing that
yeah doing that with pre-patch
yeah that's the plan yeah pre-patch will
come out and you'll be able to go start
your your blood ups and get an eye
and then content so we've got some
phases happening
yeah yeah so the content phases that we
got coming are exciting uh we're gonna
start with
uh carazon and uh and gruel's lair and
magderidon's lair
and we wanna start with just that at
release because we found with classic
that people really enjoy that kind of
gear progression
and that's where all the tier 4 gear is
with those those raids
and we want people to have an
opportunity to level up catch up to
their friends and all kind of go through
these things together
so as we unlock each chapter we want to
make sure everybody's had enough time to
to be part of that chapter and the next
chapter after that
will be phase two which will be serpent
shrine cavern and
tempest keep yeah then next we move on
to phase three which is
hyjal and the black temple um and the
reason that's a change is of course
originally
hyjal was uh was available from the
launch of burning crusade but
nobody could really get in there because
of the way the itunes worked so we'll
unlock that as a later chapter alongside
black temple
and then uh that'll go with arena season
two at that point
and then arena season three will come
out alongside zulaman with a little bit
of ketchup gear for anybody who's taken
that long to catch up
uh it's another smaller instance a 10
man
and then finally phase five will be
sunwell and arena season four
it's been a very busy year yeah yeah it
is
it's an expansion with a lot of in it
and so we spent a lot of time talking
about burning crusade classic
and burning crusade which is
exciting we're very excited about it but
there's a lot to talk about
there's a lot coming and we want to walk
through how this is going to materialize
well yeah really the question is you
know we have a diverse player base where
people have a lot of different wants and
needs
and and how do we get there how do we
get to the bernie crusade well uh
the first group of people that we wanted
to make sure that we were serving well
um is is those people who do want to go
to burning crusade we feel that most of
the community is interested in this
they're going to want to do this we want
to make it simple and easy for them
so how are we going to do that as we
said earlier you're going to be able to
make a choice
so we'll we'll talk about and explore
these choices in some detail and i'll
give you some examples
so to start with with the current
servers you're on now
classic live servers are going to become
what we're calling progression servers
and what that means
is the servers that are live now will
always
unlock any expansion we release so when
we get to our patch day
you're going to be presented with a
choice do you want to continue on into
the burning crusade
or do you want to move to classic so
in that space you're going to do that
for every single character so for my
example i'm on
warm rest accord so i've got a level 60
i am definitely taking that on through
to burning crusade but i've got a couple
of mid-levels that i know i want to move
with my friends those are
characters i level with my friends in
class and i want to continue that
journey with them
we want to make it as easy and seamless
as possible to just get right into
bernie crusade
but there are options that's that's
awesome i'm excited to hear that i i
know
um there's a lot of my friends for
example who who maybe um
didn't really play classic when it first
came out right and so now they're behind
and they're interested in playing the
burning crusade this was for a lot of
people
their favorite expansion that we've done
um we want to make sure that those
people are served too
uh and one of the ways we could do that
is provide a boost
to people who are interested in coming
back that maybe aren't interested in
doing the
the classic wow experience but really
want to hop right into outland as
quickly as possible
yeah so uh the team we spent quite a bit
of time discussing it because
we want to make sure we respect the time
of the people that um
have been playing classic for two years
but also
we want people to be able to enjoy
burning crusade if they loved it the
first time and
maybe miss classics so we are going to
offer a level 58
boost for purchase but it does come with
some restrictions so it's going to be
one per account
it's not going to be usable on blood
alpha draenei
it'll have some dungeon blues it'll have
level 40 mount skill no professions
the basics basically your outland
starting kit
that's cool that's i mean that's a
really great way to jump into the game
for sure yeah i like that i'll be
looking forward to that
uh look i know a lot of people came back
to play well classic and that's all they
want
that's all they ever wanted they're like
you know what bernie crusade that's
awesome i'm sure
some people are gonna love that but for
me i came back for walk classic um
what what what did they get to do what's
their options yeah that was really
important for us too
so um we we had all sat down and
discussed like how
we should frame this so when we get to
our patch day which is prior to
the dark portal opening when i said
before like i'll go back to my example
for worm rest we will be launching
classic era realms at the same time as
we
do our patch and you will have that
choice so
when you make the choice to go to
burning crusade classic
or you make the choice like on my
example my level 40 druid
i want to move that character to classic
era and what classic era means
is that those particular servers are
going to stay in that era forever so
that
is going to remain classic till the end
of time it's never going to unlock
expansions
you'll be able to make that choice for
every single character do you go on to
burning crusade
or do you choose to go to classic era
let's say you know
you're behind the times a little bit
you'll still be able to have that choice
there's
we haven't locked it to a time window
you're not going to miss the boat to era
the choice sounds awesome and choice and
wow is something that's meaningful it's
always been meaningful
yeah and i think it's something that's
important when we look at the community
that you're going to choose to go to the
burning crusade or you're going to
choose to go to classic
um you know some people may not be
comfortable with that choice and while
we think that that choice is important
we also recognize that there are folks
that are going to want to play
both right like yeah right here
you have some stuff left to do in
classic that you wanted and you want to
keep that
that character in classic but you also
are interested that same character wants
to read with your friends
that's exactly what you see so so what
does that look like how do we make that
happen
so we're going to actually offer a paid
service to let you make a copy of your
character and i know like copy's a big
deal
so like you said like this is something
we don't want to make uh just an
automatic choice for everybody
but i know that for me it is it really
is going to be like that that pull to go
to both places so i want to be able to
say like you know what i'm willing to
pay some money for this
i want a copy of my character that lives
in classic era forever
while i also go to burning crusade with
that god with that character
and that way i can stay with my friends
who are really excited to go to karazhan
i'm really excited to go to carazon i
want to see my hunter go through carazon
but if i'm missing like a couple pieces
of my tier three set from nexramus
i still have an opportunity to go find a
new guild there and
and go through next rammus again until i
finish that set we're going to be
spending a lot of time communicating
these details so
even as much detail as we're giving now
it's very high level there's going to be
a lot more detail to come so
keep an ear out but with that said so
pat
when's all this happening oh
so yeah this is something that you know
is important to get people are still
playing through next randomness we want
to make sure that they have enough time
to do that um but what
we are looking at uh this will be
happening in 2021
for sure we are committed to doing that
and what we're looking at is
starting the beta rather soon so
hopefully that beta will go up
and we'll get that running the community
can come and participate help us out
we'll start to hear some feedback on the
things we've talked about today uh if
there's any adjustments we need to make
we want to make sure we have a long
enough beta period for that to happen
uh and then we'll get that out to the
players so we can all enter the dark
portal
yeah it's exciting so any
final final words yeah i just i i just
talked about the beta and you know i
will say just to the community you all
uh have been so instrumental in making
classic the success that it has been
um and you will be equally instrumental
in making the burning crusade a
tremendous success also
um so please get in that beta play give
us your feedback we want to hear all
about it so
um enjoy welcome and let's have some fun
yay
yeah and it's been the highlight of my
professional career to work on wow
classic and have the support and love of
this community
uh it is really special to me and i'm
really excited to be sharing this
with all of you uh in the bernie crusade
yeah and for me
um i'm i've been playing classic since
it it launched
and i wasn't working at blizzard then um
and it's changed my life
obviously so uh from me
and the entire wow team uh we want to
thank you for bringing azeroth to life
for us
so we will definitely be seeing you in
game in whatever flavor
you choose and until then
stay classic
[Music]
dolby is a proud partner of blizzcon
line watch shock versus the world
in dolby vision and dolby atmos only in
the dolby access app
coca-cola the official refreshment of
blizzcon line
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ever since we announced diablo 4 at last
blizzcon 2019
uh we've been sharing updates with you
guys through our blog
whether it's items skills
zones even user interface updates and
you guys seem to have really enjoyed
that
today to mark the the special location
of blizzcon line on blizzard's 30th
anniversary
rather than doing a blog where we're
actually going to share lots of video
uh introduce a new class like we saw in
opening ceremonies
um and also cover some open world topics
including
uh mounts camps and pvp yeah this is
like the ultimate blog post right
we get to actually hand deliver it this
is the dream
it's all come it's all finally out there
and we can talk about all of it
just in case some of you guys missed it
during opening ceremony let's take
another look at the rogue announce video
[Music]
there is justice within the light
but you have to be patient
now pray with me
[Music]
may akharat guide and protect me
[Music]
and granted mercy and granted
mercy what are you doing here
this is not the time but this
is confession
and i have sinned
i was a thief who stole
from those more fortunate
i strayed from your light
and found my trade in the shadows
they call it murder
i say job well
[Applause]
done
i am a thief a heretic
a murderer father
will akara save me
you mark our light
but those monsters with a scourge upon
my frog
and you
you were the answer to their prayers
then we are settled and you owe me
the name you seek is
thank the heavens for you
heavens i assure you father
the heavens didn't send me
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow i i love that ending
there's two things there's the there's
the rain of arrows off the mount for the
win
and then when that guy takes the ear and
he stretches it onto that that that
that hook right at the end it's like oh
that ear box never gets old you know you
i always wonder where all those ears
from diablo 2 when you
uh kill other players went now you know
there's some creepy guy in a church
collecting ears and putting him in a box
just what we always thought no spoilers
but we're going to be hearing
a little bit more about world pvp a
little bit later in the segment but ears
are definitely making a comeback
but let's go back to the class because
there's just nothing more exciting to be
able to introduce to diablo game
than another class for players to check
out yeah this is uh this is a pretty
cool thing we don't get to do this very
often right i think it was
uh you that said that john that there's
always room around the campfire
we we had uh kind of like a very core
archetypes to begin with
the brute strength of the barbarian the
arcane knowledge of the sorceress
kind of a return of a shape-shifting
classic with the druid
no rpg lineup is complete without that
dexterity class that's
kind of like defeating enemies with
finesse with speed
and we kept coming back to just the idea
of bringing it to the kind of the
godfather
of all dexterity based archetypes the
the rogue that we saw in diablo one i
mean you got to be excited
to have the rogue back i mean i know
that like when we were exploring
different classes
like you had talked about some of your
experience with with diablo one right
oh for sure so one of one of the things
that's super cool is like
the the the rogue was always able to uh
adapt their play styles the fans of
diablo one diablo ii rogues will be able
to create very archetypical rogues
starting with the weapon selection
on the melee weapon side rogues can use
swords and daggers
as well as bows and crossbows on the
ranged side
you know just the those sort of dagger
attacks mixed with bow attacks it's like
it just looks great on screen with all
the classes having this real
strong identity as far as the animations
and what they do you think about the
the druid and shape-shifting or the
barbarian with sort of you know his leap
attacks
there's just all these great things that
you discover with the rogue that
you can't really do with other classes i
love that you can start
cosmetically from such a iconic place
where you're wearing the red armor
you kind of look like part of the
sisterhood of the the sightless eye from
the original games
you know you can maybe even uh add some
tattoos into the mix some scars
make that rogue your own or if your
fantasy of the rogue
is a more uh traditional rpg outlaw
you're definitely able to uh create that
and put on your
kind of hood and half mask and uh be
more of a shadowy character
yeah and the character customization you
kind of mentioned it being able to craft
that
you know that the the class of your your
dreams or your nightmares it was a
feature that i was honestly super
nervous about when we started because
we've never had this in a diablo game
but seeing where it is now is one of
those things that like i'm super excited
about
with where we're at there's just a lot
of creativity and fun looks and you can
be that
that you know tattooed criminal outlaw
or you can be a more noble looking kind
of
you know sort of like thief with uh with
good morals
well one of the things that that we kind
of kept running with beyond just the
cosmetics what was customization
we had this uh this niche to fill in the
class lineup that that spoke to the the
finesse player to the dexterity player
and just that everyone's idea of what
that could be was a little bit different
whether
it lean more on range or melee but uh
we we took that a little bit of a step
further we really wanted to have
each class in our game have just have
that one thing that makes you go like
that's [ __ ] when you see
a player use it and that makes you want
to reroll that class because no other
class gets it
for the rogue is the class
specialization the three specializations
are
combo points shadow realm
and exploit weakness i like shadow rom
because i can
i i take the problem and i make it
smaller i mean
it's just i just pull three guys into
the shadow realm and duke it out
and then i come back in i'm like all
right smaller problem
i i love the idea of exploit weakness
the way it works is uh
during some of the the enemy attacks
players will see an icon flash over the
enemy's head during which time they will
get to
retaliate with much more damage than an
ordinary attack
if you're quick on the draw this is the
specialization for you
i'm i'm just like a little bit skill cap
there and you know like
every time i try to make it work i'm
just just a little bit shy of the skill
level uh that's required for that
it's almost like you're a surgeon and it
requires a really
uh strong ability to assess what's
happening
all around you my my favorite my
personal favorite is the combo pone
specialization
as you might expect this ability lets
you build multiple combo points
which enhance your spender's
effectiveness in combat it
basically you just like get into this
rhythm of combat of like
three builders to a spender lets you
build up to these big
big moments it almost makes like a
rhythm game out of combat which i really
enjoy
and the way the class specializations
work is
you will work with one of the world
groups of rogues
around the world in sanctuary that you
will find and do class specific quests
that no other class can do
whether it's the sisterhood of the
sightless eye the remnants of that order
that you choose to work with
or the mercenaries of kaja stan or the
you know the outlaw smugglers
of the swamps of hawazar depending maybe
on what speaks to your
class fantasy or depending on which
specialization
speaks to you or you found more powerful
you'll be able to complete that
questline and then
activate that that specialization uh
which then you can mix and match with
any of the play styles
so you could be a combo points range or
melee player but you could also be an ex
exploit weakness
range or melee or hybrid player it just
gives the class
such such huge variety in builds and
play styles
i love how that ties into the open world
aspect
you know the ability to go to kejustan
or hauzar and get these special quests
that only the road can get
that touches on one of the things that i
love that we've done which is like
connecting
the weapons and equipment to regions
when you're when you're exploring the
world
and you pick up a sword in kejustan it's
a it's a scimitar
right if you're up in scotland which is
up in the north it's more of like a
broadsword
um you know it's this sort of like this
it's a subtle thing but i think it
really you know different armors that
you get in different regions
look like they're from the place um and
so giving that sense of place in the
world is something that
i i just i every time i play the game i
feel it i see it in just like subtle
ways
and just really enhances the overall
sense of immersion and experience and i
just want to see what's around the
corner
the weapons uh are also like going back
all the way to diablo ii
uh just such an integral part of the
class and the ability to augment your
weapon
through magic through enhancements uh is
just something that
really spoke to us when we try to tap
into the core of the class
going back to those mercenaries that you
could hire
it was always kind of cool to see what
kind of a special
arrow shot they would they would come
with and it's something we paid homage
to with
the imbue system um all the way from
directly elemental imbues like uh the
frosting view which
feels uh a lot like the the the ice
arrows that the d2 mercenaries used to
shoot
uh all the way to uh we expanded to feel
a little grittier a little darker into
things like poison imbue and shadow
imbue
uh just the ability to take uh any any
sort of attacks and kind of
mix and match with those imbues once
that kind of clicked for me that i could
take any ability and imbue it with
you know either of those elements rain
of arrows with frost and rain of arrows
with
acid is completely different right like
you're essentially freezing the
battlefield
um and then i just love poison imbue
because of the
the gruesome death that all the monsters
experienced
uh and we've had a ton of fun making
that art so it's always fun to kind of
see that
you know just a field of goatman melt
into nothing you know you just kill
everything on the screen in a
in a in a gory mess uh which i i never
really gets old
it's a really flexible way to take a
build that you're already comfortable
with that you already like
say you like you know you're really
comfortable with flurry and shadow stuff
as
kind of your melee skills and you find
yourself needing more uh crowd control
without changing your play style you can
just add the frosting view uh to your
bar
and now you're able to use those same
ability to slow down
enemies or build up to a full freeze
yeah and frost and view plays pretty
well with uh group play as well right
you know where i can freeze an enemy and
somebody else can blow it up or also uh
the way that like uh chills work in the
game uh they build up to a full freeze
so if you you know your best buddy is a
sorceress player uh
your chill spells and your frost imbues
uh chills will actually build up uh
faster than if you were uh using a
single player
so you know just uh ask to open with
blizzard before you frost and view and
you'll you're basically freezing enemies
twice as fast which is
super awesome synergy so uh the last
thing um
that's worth spending some time talking
about the rogue it's like
how mobile the class is just how able
the class is to kind of close the gap
between themselves and the enemy
even while they're mounted you might
find yourself you know a full screen
away
and just dismounting into a rain of
arrows closing the rest of that gap with
maybe like a dash and then getting back
out of there
dropping some caltrops they can
basically control
the the fluid motion of combat in a way
that no other class can
that's something that beyond all of the
other customization options that you
have whether it's
the play style whether it's the range at
which you engage with enemies
whether it's the cosmetics just the
sheer mobility of the class
lets you just adapt to the situations
even
even when you you would have totally
been toast as another class
a room full of elites you're able to use
offensive abilities in creative ways
abilities like uh
shadow stuff right like abilities like
shadow realm abilities like dash
you're able to kind of like use them to
your advantage in a way that gets you
out of a very dangerous situation
by picking that one lone uh skeleton
archer
that maybe is not surrounded by
everything else you can shadow step
there get out of the way and you know
live to fight another day which just
feels like such a rogue thing to do
when i play the rogue i really do feel
like like surgical precision
you know i really feel like i can i can
move through the whole screen
without uh it feels kind of effortless
um and almost sometimes a little unfair
it's like when i go into shadow realm
and i'm dashing i'm like am i cheating
did i just break the game
and we'll hear more about pvp in a
little bit but i i just couldn't
go without mentioning that some of our
most feared pvp players on the team
play rogue and just the way they're able
to like surprise you you might be with a
group of friends and
just that mobility lets them go to the
middle of the group unleash a reign of
arrows that's frost imbued and
before you know it you're all frozen and
looking at a rogue while you're frozen
let me tell you there are fewer scarier
things in our game right now than that
so louise this was uh i mean this is
like the ultimate blog post this has
been a lot of fun getting to share a new
addition to the campfire
um and of course there's probably more
in the future right we always say
there's a little bit more room around
that campfire
that's right and that pretty much wraps
it up for the road so why don't we go to
joe and karina
and learn a little bit more about those
open world features that we promised
well thank you to luis and john for
introducing the rogue which
i'm i'm really excited that we finally
got a chance to talk about and announce
to the community and we're here today to
talk to you about
diablo 4 and the open world now i think
maybe the
the best way to start this conversation
uh karina would be just to for me to ask
you
like what are you what are you most
excited about what we're adding in
diablo 4 for the open world
what what feature what what mechanic
what what are you most excited to talk
about first
i am really excited about uh
just exploring the world i am a huge
completist
naturally that's the way i play and i
love exploring and looking after every
single nook and cranny the more
this game has been growing particularly
since last blizzcon
the more fun i am having just riding
around the open world
on my mount and exploring everything i
possibly can yeah it's it's really fun i
think
uh now that we've kind of taken
sanctuary just made it so much
larger when you're playing through the
game you know when you compare it to
like diablo 3 or diablo 2
there's tons of like exploration and and
and
movement throughout the world in those
games obviously but now that we've
really been able to embrace
the open world concept we can really
dive much deeper
into like what how does sanctuary
actually all fit together
like be able to ride from uh scott's
glitch the fractured peaks like be like
it's very very interesting that way
one of the things about that that i
think is really neat is uh the
collection
aspect of mounts so i mean there's all
these horses
horse breeds and other other mounts you
can find throughout the world
from completing puzzles or just finding
hidden locations
or slaying certain particular kinds of
monsters find various
horses or things to customize your horse
with like uh like a horse armor
there are uh hoof plates you can get and
trophies to show off your
accomplishments
there's lots of different ways to make
sure that you can personalize your mount
make it really feel like it's your
companion yeah that's really cool that
like like you mentioned the whole shoes
you get to actually
change the speed at which your horse can
run and it's something i like
to be able to customize the horse to the
type of game play that i like to enjoy
as a player
that's it's really really fun i like the
amount of variety that you give us
and i mean there's there's more to
mounts than just that as well
it's like one thing we know we didn't
want to do either with mounts in diablo
4 is we didn't want to have like
jousting
this idea of like fighting from
horseback it's not really the diablo
experience
right yeah that's something i'm super
excited for um
like we showed last blizzcon we had the
sorceress we showed her
dismount skill eye stash where she
shoots forwards off her amount and
destroys everything in her path but with
the rogue we got to have a little bit
more fun with it
and the animation department has done a
fantastic job of having her
leap up into the air and uh fire down
like the reign of arabs that destroys
everything
um it's really really cool it feels
really good yeah you're like
leaping from your saddle and just
raining arrows down on your enemies as
you pass by
getting down the frame then starting to
print like stab people and poison people
like
that that is that is spot on what we're
looking for being able to jump in
engage with enemies uh from your horse
and then just
fight it out duke it out using your
skills and everything else like we want
it's interesting that
your mount can't get damaged but if a
monster actually attacks you while
you're mounted you will actually be
forced to dismount so there is a
flip side of actually judging for
yourself when you do want to use that
skill
in order to prevent you from being
forced off unintentionally yeah there's
definitely a little bit of gameplay
there to make sure that you're using it
in a way that is most appropriate to
help you get where you're trying to go
and also fight the monsters you want to
fight one of the things i'm most excited
about for the uh for the open world
right now is this feature
we have called camps so camps are
basically these uh
strongholds of evil out in the overworld
now you gotta remember that you know
decades ago uh during the events of
reaper of souls
you know when malfield rose to power the
reapers killed like nine out of ten
people
uh throughout sanctuary like a
tremendous number of people passed away
uh now there's a big power vacuum out
here you know you know decades later
and these these monsters have started to
move into these places bandits
monsters goat men all kinds of different
creatures skeletons the undead
have started to like resurface and come
back into these areas and start to take
them for themselves
you as the hero of sanctuary get to kind
of wander through these spaces
and begin to reclaim them for the people
of sanctuary
that's part of what makes them really
really need each of them have their own
story
they're their own unique fixed place in
the world unlike quests quests are
something that happens randomly in the
world and
you can come across them anywhere camps
are a permanent fixture that
you as the player when you come across
that evil you can actually have a real
impact on the open world that everyone
else can see because
once you have defeated that evil one of
the really fun things
is that you you basically unlock that
camp and you
you make a new waypoint that previously
didn't exist for yourself but like
suddenly all the marketplaces open up
and now you have a blacksmith vendor and
a location that previously didn't exist
which i think is really really cool
now what we're looking at here this was
a village
at the village of carissu which now has
fallen to ruins
you know the people here in the dry
steps had a problem the problem was
there were bloodthirsty cannibals that
dwelled nearby and would regularly raid
their community
and the people had come up with a
solution they weren't strong enough to
defend themselves from these cannibals
so they made a dark bargain with a demon
and they were able to gather enough
power to push these cannibals out
and protect their community but not
without great cost as we can see
here you're kind of helping resettle
parts of sanctuary in many ways when you
take these camps back from the enemy
vendors will come back and now suddenly
there might be like new quest givers new
stories need to be told
dungeon entrances can appear uh in some
of these places afterwards like there's
all kinds of things that occur
after you take over the camp and
liberate it from these forests of
darkness
and again it's just so so cool to see
you permanently change the world
as you find these places and kind of
wander through and solve these problems
one of the other neat things about camps
and in general like the overworld just
broadly speaking
is we have so many more opportunities
now uh to kind of play with movement
it pushes the the bar vertically as well
as horizontally
and we now have been playing around with
the idea of jumping across
chasms to allow the player to get access
to a location that they previously
didn't have
there's uh there's all kinds of areas
players like find their own path
allowing them extra movement options
they haven't had in previous diablo
games we are also in a vertical
top-down camera for the environment and
so it really breaks up the plane that
you typically see
as like not only as a developer as an
animator but also as a player there's
such a huge variety
of things that you can possibly do to
mix it up and make things a little bit
different
there's like certain puzzle elements to
it that it's not so straightforward and
not always obvious so
it's not just a matter of running
through the world and getting
you know to your goal it's you have to
think about it yeah definitely
now karina i know that you're very
excited about pvp
i'm a huge fan of pvp i love the first
time that we all actually had a chance
to as a whole team
play pvp because the amount of feedback
that that generated i think it took
design like three days to go through it
all
and what that showed me is that i find
everyone either they either love it or
they hate it
and i i personally love it i really
enjoy it so the way that pvp works is
that
the uh hatred of mephisto has been
bubbling up from hell
and has created these areas in the open
world that you can freely walk into
that kind of consumes you and makes you
turn
against your fellow players pdp even in
these areas these um
these fields of hatred right even in
these spaces it's not like mandatory so
these are optional places players can
choose to go
uh to kind of collect shards of hatred
that they can they can collect from like
killing monsters
from completing events opening chests
all kinds of ways to earn these things
not necessarily just killing players
and as you earn these shards of hatred
they're kind of in an unpurified state
they're in a basic
state you need to bring them to a
purification event
in order to turn them into a currency
that you can then use
in the nearby like small encampments
around the fields of hatred and what's
really neat about that
is that when you're trying to purify
these things that's when everybody
nearby
finds out and here's like okay well
someone's actually trying to complete a
publication which will need to go
and kill those players and take all of
their shards before they finish
once you purify them they're yours you
can't lose them but uh
but before they're purified their free
game yeah i think it's really important
to note that like
even if you don't want to engage with
other pvp players you can actually
explore those areas and collect the
shadows of hatreds from specifically
monsters
but the second you need to then turn
them in and purify them into a currency
where you can spend them on gear
trophies and other content you actually
are hostile yourself and actually can be
attacked during that single moment but i
think that really um creates a lot of
opportunity for you to team up with
friends
for just that one little moment in order
to gain the reward that you spent so
much time collecting
so you call it earlier that uh the
shards of hatred are used for like some
of the vendors you could find in the
fields of hatred
uh there are some special vendors that
only kind of arrive in these areas
they'll have special costumes or new
mounts
and weapons and things along those lines
nothing that's like strictly more
powerful than stuff you can get other
parts of the game but stuff that really
like speaks to your desire as a pvp
player
and i think one of the things that's
really kind of neat about the system in
general is that
as a player if you choose to go hostile
betray your other up betray the players
you're
near you try to get as many shards of
hatred as you can you're going to slowly
begin to kind of like
infuse yourself with that same curse of
mephisto
you're going to become a vessel of
hatred now once you do that
everyone within a very large radius of
you is able to see you
as a threat on the map and they're going
to get a bonus for killing you
so if when that occurs you have a set
amount of time you need to survive
and if you're able to do that without
running away or jumping a town portal
and trying to escape
if you're able to do that and finish
that period and manage to escape or
or defeat your you know people who are
coming to try to destroy you uh you're
gonna get a really big bonus at the end
and that's been really really exciting
to watch in our play tests already as
people were like
kind of wrestling for the status and
then trying to defend it once they
actually achieve it yeah and
there's also the uh ears that you get to
collect as a trophy um it harkens back
to
d2 where i think you could sell the ears
for one gold i don't know if we're going
to be doing that i know we were playing
around with them
as a currency at one point but i think
right now it's just a cool trophy that
you get to collect and show off
yeah right now very very cool trophy the
thing was really neat about the diablo 2
ears like you could fill up your whole
inventory with them obviously but
be able to see like the the people that
you took the ears from like seeing
their character names on there was
always like the really the interesting
fun part kind of proof like yeah i got
i got that person that time right so we
want to make sure that we embrace that
aspect of it that's the important part
for us
i think that's going to be a really
really great call back to diablo 2 pvp
right yeah so i'm i'm i love where pvp
is going and i love that it is such a
it's only one part of how large and open
the world is
and really harkens back to the adventure
in me when i play the game how do you
feel
i'm super excited as well i mean there's
so much to look forward to in diablo 4
right now like what we talk about today
just scratches the surface
in general as a diablo fan there's a lot
to be looking forward to in the free on
the franchise in the future
uh thank you so much for watching today
we look forward to speaking to you more
about this game
and others in the future
[Music]
welcome everybody to blizzcon we know
that you all want to hear more about
overwatch 2.
[Music]
allow us to invite you behind the scenes
to explain more of what we're doing and
why
everybody please hit record fingers
crossed we lost scott
it's off to a good start this is going
great
we've been assembling one of the best
teams that i have ever worked with
i'm nervous and i'm so proud
of the progress that we have made
together
we really liked the stylized drop down
imagine that
it's coming forward boom boom this
starts to spin the scale and the scope
of this game
have meant that we've needed to grow
substantially just have we have to
sorry let me start overall i think we've
done
incredibly well as a team moving to work
from home
oh she had a play there have definitely
been challenges
but the team is really putting
everything we've got behind this game
to me it's the next big step in the
overwatch universe
new heroes game modes major story beats
with competitive and pve i see overwatch
2 as the overwatch for
all of my friends you know we're always
inspired by what
historian franchise development does
with their animated shorts
we really wanted to bring that cinematic
experience into the game
you can invest in your heroes and grow
them over time
i'm super geeked out about overwatch too
i can't wait for people to play this
game it just gets better and better
there are some things that we just can't
do without a sequel
so thank you so much for your patience
so far
and i hope you enjoyed this behind the
scenes look
at overwatch 2.
all of our players at home they want to
see one of the new maps
that we've never talked about before
really i can just like
i can just talk about anything that i
want to
yeah you're serving this up to the guy
that is like
unintentionally leaked information in
past
interviews you can do it officially now
okay so one of the maps that i'm
i'm most excited for in overwatch 2 is
our roam
map
we always want overwatch to feel like
this globetrotting adventure for our
players
so we're having a lot of fun coming up
with the overwatch version of rome
we wanted a very romantic sort of this
powerful feeling
of old world architecture one of the
most exciting things for me
is the early building of these maps
where we get to sit down together with
key people from the environment team
level designers
effects groups we'll spend some time
talking about
moments in the game that we really want
to see like the coliseum
or a grand view of the hills of rome in
the backdrop and then we'll go back
and do a paint over or we'll do a
concept painting of certain things based
on that
we try to draw inspiration from as many
different sources as possible for
example
one of our environment artists had just
taken a trip to rome
and he returned with thousands of
pictures and was
so excited um to work on a map
set in italy there's a lot of ancient
architecture in rome that
represents the empire that it used to be
so we brought some of that back
some of the things that are destroyed in
real life we kind of
rebuilt in a kind of overwatch style
it's one of the most
beautiful pieces of environment art that
i think we've made
for the entire game and it just
absolutely took my breath away
can we reveal more maps yes scott
scott why don't you have the honor why
don't you reveal like is there an
artifact like let's pick an artified one
i know what map i want to talk about
it's the one that i just get super
excited about
new york city new york city is
just an amazing overwatch location
we're really striving to make it as
authentic as possible while still
putting this overwatch spin on it
there's a lot of amazing buildings and
architecture pieces that just
especially for artists stands out a lot
and they usually use this kind of
art deco style from the 1920s 1950s
we started in an area that's a little
bit like the village
there's some smaller shops there there's
a fire station
little pizza places and things that
people that are familiar
with new york city will either recognize
or maybe
see the reference that we're trying to
make with some of our different
locations
it feels like something you haven't seen
in other games before because it's
uniquely overwatch
[Music]
well we should move on otherwise we just
have to reveal
more maps so we were talking about pvp
and you know one thing that i think is
really interesting
about pvp in overwatch too
is some of the philosophical changes
we're making to the approach pvp feels
different new we're upgrading our combat
feel
the roles are playing differently when
it comes to all new maps
it's a pretty big departure uh from
where we are
on live right now so i i can't wait to
see where we end up with it by the time
we launch this thing
we're also experimenting with the idea
we call roll passives which are passive
abilities that a hero can have
based on what role they are for example
currently in our internal builds
the tank heroes all have knockback
reduction against them
and they also generate less ultimate
charge for enemies they're shooting at
them
james dealing heroes have a movement
speed bonus which is great for
flanking around the map and uh healing
heroes support heroes have
automatic healing that kicks in after
they haven't taken damage profile very
similar to mercy's passive but a little
bit of a lower rate
one of the more shocking changes that
we've been exploring
in overwatch 2 pvp is it changed the
tank roll
entirely that's applied to all of the
tanks
we want to try to make them more
toe-to-toe brawlers
and less characters that just stand back
and protect
other people so for example for
reinhardt we've given him two charges of
fire strikes we can throw fire strikes a
lot more
aggressively and more often also his
charge he's able to cancel it now
and you can steer it more aggressively
so you can you know not quite turn a
corner but you can definitely more
accurately
pin targets and because you can cancel
it it allows you to use it much more
aggressively and
you know really go after those key
targets without feeling like you're
going to sacrifice
you know all of your positioning
everything to get there he's almost more
terrifying now with us to be able to
unleash his full arsenal more often than
kind of just being the guy with a shield
the changes to reinhardt that we're
trying
and they might not shift that's just the
reality but the changes
that we're trying right now are to try
to embrace
more of that instinct that players have
when they want to play
a big burly character that looks
aggressive
and feels like it should be aggressive
shortly after blizzcon we we spun up
this group our combat feel group
to really just work on what happens
when a player holds the trigger we're
putting a ton of effort into
looking at all of our characters and
trying to
give them even a more visceral weapon
feel
from sound to vfx to animation
to the design of these units all new
sounds for for a lot of our weapons in
the game and a whole new
sound system that's driving it and we
didn't just level up a unit
we leveled up the rest of the game
when we first started working on
overwatch you know we spent quite a bit
of time working on
gunfire sounds and just general combat
feel to make it feel really awesome
we're revisiting pretty much everything
nothing's off the table so we're looking
at
even kind of small things such as quick
melee attacks that every hero has so
they have kind of new audio paths and a
new kind of
feel and the visual effect we hit things
one of the bigger efforts we're
undertaking for overwatch 2
is what we're calling our weapon 2.0
sound pass
what this is a big overhaul to the
weapon systems in the game
that means the way the gun feels in your
hands you could feel the ammo running
out as you're getting lower on the cliff
we've really tried to
amplify those sounds to better
encapsulate the gameplay
and the gun play that comes with
overwatch 2.
another key for the weapons was getting
them to feel like they're in the
environment this meant working with
convolution reverb it's a new system
that we've implemented into overwatch
it's a way that we can capture the
acoustics of an environment
and transport it onto the sounds that
we're using so we went and captured
tales of guns in different environments
through our weapon shoots
and then we've cut them and applied it
so that we can support a lot more
environments
now we're sporting outdoor urban
outdoor warehouse tails
tight tunnels small rooms and it gives a
lot more presence to the weapons in the
way that they react in the world
the shooter genre has evolved a lot
since overwatch one came out
on top of that i think we really want to
push the visceral nature of how we do
combat
so we focused a lot not just on the
wonderful sound effects but
also with how the the gun moves as you
shoot you know
so you can really feel every single shot
leaving the chamber and there's a lot of
subtle little tweaks we have to do
on the gameplay engineering side to make
that feel really visceral
everything from making sure that the
camera shakes are crisp
making sure that if you get shot you
know exactly these tight indicators show
up on the outside of your reticle
all these things play into making the
game feel not just
tight and responsive but also modern and
up to date
take 76 for example what we wanted to do
in overwatch 2 with his weapon was to
make it really
feel incredibly powerful and that
happens with a bunch of different
elements that mixed together
but it really feels like the gun is
almost just outside of your control
a lot of that comes down to this camera
shake technology where every set every
time you fire the weapon
you want to feel like it's running
through your entire body and the camera
shake gives that extra bite to every
single shot out of the chamber
it makes him feel really great you guys
got a sneak peek of
sojourn from last blizzcon she's been
under development for quite a while
and she's actually quickly at this point
become a lot of people's favorites
in-house when we look back at overwatch
when it was originally
created um there was a lot of heroes
that were made from a gameplay
standpoint kind of surrounding
a weapon type for example pharah was
based on a rocket launcher hero
widowmaker is clearly like kind of the
sniper we thought there was a weapon
that was kind of
missing that would be a lot of fun to
play with and that's a railgun it's so
much fun in the play test to have this
really powerful shot that can
you know rip through enemies if you
really are accurate with it and she's
she's all about that aim skill so if you
got that aim skull you'll love her
we're still exploring new game modes and
we're also
reevaluating older game modes
that people are more critical of you
know we're of the mindset
maybe maybe 2cp doesn't exist in
overwatch 2
and maybe there's a new cool game mode
that replaces it
we really want overwatch 2 to feel like
the next evolution a true
sequel to the first game not an add-on
it's not a small part it's not an
extension
of the original game this is an
evolution and a replacement to the
original game
and i think it's exciting
hero missions are probably one of the
things that's the hardest to wrap your
head around if you've never
played one of them
[Music]
the goal around hero missions is for
these to be
this co-op pve experience
i personally only play competitive mode
like i'm all about that competition
and i have friends that they don't want
to do that at all so i'm really looking
forward to a game that i can play
hours and hours with with my friends who
aren't in competitive and it's also
something that
i'm interested in hero missions are the
content that people are playing
as they are leveling up their heroes and
so for
a system like this to really sing you
need
a lot of mission we don't want players
who feel like they're just in this grind
to get to the top
and there's a lot of really really good
back end technology that we're exploring
so the heroes are constantly bringing
their personality
and some light story to these hero
missions as well
the goal is to make as many as possible
hundreds
of hero missions we've explored a lot of
different ways of getting
to that much content still have like
different sets of enemy units that
people
will be fighting against and there's
different hero mission types
at the same time hero missions can take
place in all of the multiplayer maps
that we've done
and we're also adding new spaces onto
some of these maps
it's a huge challenge for the art team
we take maps that
a lot of people love and recognize and
we have to add a lot more
art and level design to it in this one
hero mission play test
we came up to an area in king's row that
usually has a gate on it
suddenly that gate opened and i saw a
new
area of king's row that i had never seen
before
you may be playing a payload game type
and the payload may decide to take this
new route instead of
going the usual route that was really
really cool it was like this eye-opening
special moment
lan our lead tech artists on the
environment side
very early on our own free time made a
prototype of a sandstorm
on the temple of anubis map and at the
time we didn't know what we wanted to do
with that but it looked awesome
we looked at and went oh my god we
absolutely have to do this
so we put some new technology in place
that allows us to do this dynamically
you start the mission off clear day
midway through the mission suddenly this
sandstorm or heavy weather would show up
it made the
world just feel so much more alive
there's a sunset daytime nighttime but
depending on where you are in the world
these look different
california or hollywood would have what
we call a california sun
new bonnie there's a great african sun
that happens there you start to get a
sense of space and mood
this is what really brings the levels to
life
me the dynamic world's exciting just
seeing these dramatic
landscapes the wind and the atmosphere
blowing by it's a much more cinematic
experience for the player before you
start a mission you look at a map
it's nighttime in necropolis or there's
a sandstorm in necropolis
players can make some comp choices based
on knowing this information
characters like hanzo or widowmaker
start to be a little more valuable
because they have
abilities that allow them to see through
the sand more clearly
are we gonna talk about any of the types
of objectives
in hero missions yeah let's let's talk
about the objectives
players are being asked to do different
things from one hero mission to the next
so that they all feel really fresh to
the player
for example we have gathering return
where you're trying to go and grab these
different canisters to kind of safeguard
them so they don't go off and affect the
population in a negative way
it creates this really cool tension in
the world where on the one hand
you're trying to split up and go grab
all these canisters to be as efficient
as possible
but at the same time now you're having
these sort of special enemy units spawn
that are really difficult and if you
kind of get caught by yourself
it turns into a pretty bad situation
really quickly it feels extremely
cooperative and like a very different
way to interact with the overwatch
universe
we're experimenting with all sorts of
ideas and just internally we have names
like
wall of death scavenger hunt and kill
quests and all these
new mechanics and enemies for people to
experience
players will be able to jump in night
after night play different hero missions
and then work through the progression
system leveling up their heroes
[Music]
at blizzcon in 2019 we started to talk
about progression
and we showed the very early version
of our talent system which i think was
really cool we had that one talent where
like
mate became the rolling snowball which
was a big hit
we've really blown that system out i'm
really excited about talents you can
play
the same hero in so many different ways
now with a skill tree
you can have fun every night doing
different things and kind of
experimenting
yeah the talent system is like really
deep and rich and
every single hero has different trees
you might
open up 76's tree and as you're leveling
and picking new talents you're starting
to feel your hero change
we've had some pretty hilarious versions
of the healing one where
his biotic field travels with him it
also repulses enemies we called it the
snowplow build
where 76 is like running through spaces
pushing enemies away from them
designing these is super fun because
it's like we get to break all the rules
that we've sort of established for
ourselves and
we get to really take the gloves off and
do crazy things like junkrat can do
wield grenade launchers and
we've had mercy be able to area effect
rez their whole team at once at super
long range through walls
it's been a ton of fun kind of like mad
scientists making all this stuff you're
all used to using these kind of kinetic
weapons like soldier 76's rifle
or fire attack like what reinhardt's
flame strike does
as soon as you start to mutate these
things with talents all of a sudden
maybe you're doing
freeze damage or electrical damage but
it gives the animators a bunch of crazy
opportunities you know the animations
are going to change to show them
freezing and shattering
and if you you know shock someone with a
lighting attack they can shake in place
it's done maybe chained to other enemies
all sorts of stuff to make you feel like
you're controlling the battlefield
in novel ways as a huge rpg nerd myself
the first time i opened up the talent
tree systems it was like
oh my gosh this is this is speaking my
love language like
i just want to plan and i want to see
like where do i want to invest and how
am i going to play this character
yes it's so great you like you start at
the bottom of the tree
like oh my exactly like tracer gets to
do what
and then you start working and kind of
planning how you're going to get down
there
it's like ah that's so fun
when we look back at blizzcon 2019
and we talk about some of the criticisms
that we had
one of them as a development team that
we felt was that the combat
was just not engaging enough so the fact
that our combat
wasn't highly engaging to us as players
meant that we had a problem with the
enemy units
and that they just weren't feeling
interesting enough just because we show
something to the public
it doesn't mean that that is what it's
going to be if we make discoveries where
things aren't working how we want
they're not reading how we want they're
not fun enough
we're totally down to reinvestigate
reiterate and just
really find ways to level kind of all
aspects of things until they feel good
i would say a major focus of all of 2020
was to make the null sector enemy units
more engaging and some of this was
adding new units and
evolving other units that we had
interesting combat for us
is varied combat for us so
sometimes we're going to ask you to
protect something in overwatch too
sometimes we're just going to ask you to
get someplace sometimes we might ask you
to escort something
across a map while it's being attacked
and so it's a different type of spawning
and it's a different type of units that
are that are in there and it's a simpler
objective
there's a lot of units aaron is talking
about lots of different units lots of
different types they serve different
purposes you do different things to them
it's really going to help a lot of us
find the fun and make sure that
overwatch 2
is a blast one of those sets of of
enemies is what we internally
call objective units and they're
typically units that
don't even attack players the simplest
version would be something like
the breacher it's two legs with this
huge bomb on its back
it was built to do one thing slowly and
methodically
march towards its objective and then it
transforms
and the bomb opens up like a flower it
starts spinning and charging
up and you hear this awesome sound and
you know you have a little bit of time
before it's going to explode and you
have to take it out
we have units like the slicers which you
guys have seen before they they're
little
we call them the chickens they little
chicken slides are right there really
fast
you know we have a guy we're friendly
right now who flies and drops these
bombs that create these
kind of ever expanding smoke fields that
you have to escape from because they're
super deadly
so you really get to use your mobility
options to kind of escape that there's
things like
the polar you could be moving through
these
darker alleys and as soon as you hear
that polar spawn
it suddenly becomes like really spooky
and kind of scary
this very tall elegant looking character
that's blindfolded
three orbs that circle around her as her
eyes
and we basically spun those orbs around
her head as a big tell
launch them at the player and then
activate this tractor beam and it's
bringing you in
and bringing you in and then you get
this awesome like anticipation of the
hair
opening up so you know what's about to
happen
one thing we've just recently been
experimenting with is this idea of
elite units we didn't want the elite
units to feel like they're just oh this
guy's got double health and double
damage
we want to make sure the units feel like
they have different behaviors and have
different attacks
so for example an omnic run normally he
just kind of he fires his gun
he dies pretty simply if you fight elite
crunch
his weapon fires in a burst fire pattern
it's very deadly if you're close
and if you manage to take them out they
don't just die right away they instead
can crawl on the ground towards you and
you
you know you try to back away um because
you know if they get to you they can
explode
artillery at blizzcon we're all just
staring at this
and we're like what is what are we gonna
do to level this up one of the things we
really felt wasn't coming through
was the damage states we intend for
players to shoot these guns off
but currently it's not reading as
something that can happen in the game
easily
we change the design we change the
animation and we go back and forth and
just continually
iterate we decided hey you know what
we're going to just delete half of these
damage states so now it's super readable
from an animation standpoint
we decided on spinning barrel version
just did this really nice kickback
the tip of the barrel opens up when it's
about to fire and it
shifts into place and boom that's
really amazing to be fighting an
artillery unit and you can see the guns
on the side as you're shooting the guns
they're actually visibly taking damage
and then
you can blow them off and it reacts and
kind of stumbles to the side and really
makes you feel like you're there and
it's super fun
in a lot of the stuff we've showed so
far you're fighting a mill sector these
are
evil killing machines intent on marching
you down the way you're going to stop
them is by shooting them
and we want to make sure that feels
responsive and visceral
really making sure that when they take a
hit it feels like their whole body has
been punched almost like hit by a truck
that's what really sells this fantasy
that you're playing these superheroes
one of the cool pieces of technology
that we created was what we call chain
hit reactions
oftentimes you'll find multi-sector
bunched up marching
maybe a half a dozen units of rest you
expect if you shoot one
they're going to knock them with their
buddies so we made that happen
turns out it's really fun too
one of the things that we showed last
year at blizzcon was the new looks for
our heroes
the theory kind of going in was like you
want to preserve the essence of your
hero
but also kind of show that the heroes
evolved and kind of change and move
forward
so we have a lot more new looks so i'm
excited to see how
players and fans react to all of the
ones that we've done so far maybe we'll
share some of those
new looks today which would be cool
we're going to reveal mccree's new look
for overwatch 2 as well
as farah and we're really excited to
show off some of our first villains
with reaper and widowmaker but first i
wanted to talk a little bit about
technical wear kind of like technical
clothing what that really is is
using you know very techy fabrics as
well as
you know having very intricate but
functional straps designed in a way that
is very aesthetically pleasing with
mccree we took a couple different
approaches
he's got this classic cowboy look that
it's really hard to mess with because
if you try to make him too sophisticated
or too techy it might not feel right for
the character
but as a concept artist you always want
to change things around and try
different shapes
and silhouettes so we did identify as
red sarape as
the main thing for mccree we also tried
a couple different things with increased
cowboy hat
we didn't really want to mess with that
too much because that's a very iconic
part of him
so that's another piece that we that we
kept we tried some
retro cowboy looks that mixed in some
tech here and there
um some that were a little bit more
techy than others some that were a
little bit more
classic cowboy we gave them a little bit
of a longer beard
and it really gives them a nice kind of
like a more aging look
what's different about pharah than some
of our other heroes is
farrah's completely covered in armor we
didn't want to change her silhouette too
much
it was more about experimenting on
different colors so it
felt really appropriate for her to be
the one to hearken back
to those original overwatch colors of
white and blue
one of the things that we wanted to
update on farah was her visor
instead of being completely opaque and
reflective we tried a little bit more of
a transparent approach
and being able to see through it a
little bit now allows us to see some of
her
some more of her emotions reaper was
actually the ones i was very excited to
work on because
i could see a lot of potential in how we
can integrate his cloak
and his cowl and his armor and how we
can make all those shapes really sing
within that classic you know reaper
silhouette
we tried a couple takes with the first
pass like completely silver arms
more layers to his jacket reaper's mask
is obviously
pretty sacred to us but the thing you'll
notice immediately is that it's now
completely silver
instead of the bone white he's got this
like almost like deadly edgy silver
that just gives him that classic reaper
look with widowmaker we started with the
idea stage
exploring a breath of ideas we tried
things like a more insectoid approach
treasure hunter one of them made her
feel like a classic bond villain so we
kind of steered it back towards one of
the more cyberpunk looking ones almost
like a futuristic
femme battal which is basically what
widowmaker is but she even feels more
upgraded so i'm super glad that we went
down this route we played with different
hairstyles too
widowmaker has the really long ponytail
that's really
key part of her look and really liked
the hairstyle on
one of the designs that was more of a
parade and it was really interesting
look that also preserves widowmaker's
original silhouette with that long
ponytail
we've been working a lot with our domino
engine
and making our cloth look better now
that we have this cloth tech
we're going to be able to make some
really cool unique silhouettes that will
help them stand out from other heroes
we put a lot of time and effort into our
face rig and what i mean by that is
we'll be able to get really close to
these characters and it's going to feel
really cool it is absolutely worth the
time and effort
to invest in the technology and that way
we can make these characters
do more things that we haven't really
been able to do before it's been super
exciting working on the new looks for
overwatch 2
and it's just been so inspiring to watch
the team try things that we've never
tried before and i just can't wait to
show up more in the future
overwatch 2 is probably the
largest opportunity we've had since the
inception of the franchise
to really expand what overwatch even
means
to our players in zero hour we saw that
some of the heroes
got back together but we're also seeing
that there seems to be
a second huge omnic uprising
we're gonna learn who's behind that
uprising
why that's happening how globally spread
is it
the story and franchise development
group they were really the torchbearers
of what
the big story is that we were going to
tell for this game
we have a lot of interaction with them
they're working on
in-game cinematic intros and outros
for every one of our story missions it's
been really great to see this
collaboration grow and develop
the story is just a little more
integrated into our missions than it
ever really has been before
all the available heroes get dialogue
for a given mission
we have npcs we have multiple hero
choices
we have all sorts of events that are
happening that are
driving players to interact with each
other
or parts of the environment there are
other characters
do your world of overwatch this bright
shiny future so
how do you take that bright shiny future
and create conflict in it how dark can
the world of overwatch go
the different challenges that these
characters are going to have to overcome
in overwatch 2
are things that they haven't ever dealt
with before or dealt with on this scale
so what we had to do was literally strip
it down to those bare bones
of where are these characters in their
lives overwatch has been disbanded
and now there's a situation where the
world's in trouble again
and the world needs the heroes again but
they're not allowed to be
doing what they were supposed to be
doing
we started to book these off-site
locations
so we could brainstorm over and over
different versions of what the overwatch
2
story campaign could be and we basically
had these white boards that we were
carting around everywhere the room was
filled with whiteboards and we would
just write every day
story beats with the characters and who
was doing what and where and oh my gosh
we forgot this character
we had these giant sticky notes and each
one of them would be a mission with a
bunch of notes on it
you know somebody say well what if we
moved rio to the end and they'd
physically grab it off the wall
and stick it on the end and we did this
for a while you know until we all felt
that it was
pretty close to what we wanted then we
could send it to our writers rooms the
writer reforms then had a much
clearer direction of where we wanted
this process to go
ultimately we come up with something
that we think is right
for the game and then we pitch it back
to the game team and they point out
everything that uh we missed
and that allows us to actually back up
and go and make it right and make it
better
because the scale of this story is so
huge it takes place over the whole world
basically
it just requires a constant iteration
constant refinement to make the story as
best as we can make it
from writing we go to storyboards the
storyboards get crafted with the edit
from there it'll go to a previz
department where they'll start to
flush it out in 3d once we've kind of
figured out our camera work and our
cinematography that'll then go to the
animation department
and then we end up going right into the
game engine
one of our challenges was to figure out
how to integrate this story and this
narrative
with the gameplay so if the intro
cinematic ends with this huge battle
this huge war
when you get into the game it has to
mesh and feel the exact same way and
blend together
we really are also trying to get the
music to be equally as consistent from
in-game cinematics straight through to
the mission adam burgess
our lead composer has been working with
the igc team with the game team
developing themes for all the heroes
all of the locations as the cinematic
director
whatever we're crafting should never
override the gameplay
we want to make sure that the players
experience going from the cinematic to
the gameplay
is seamless and it feels like a
completely immersive experience
the engineers we have to find a way to
actually make that come to fruition the
choreo tool is a tool that allows people
to
coordinate different events to happen at
the same time like in rio if you've
played our demo one of the buildings
explodes and so
that kind of event needs to happen as
you're running by and you need to have
at times because if it blows up too
early then you don't see it
it allows story moments in missions that
interact with the environment that
interact with our characters
the new tech the new abilities that we
have now are allowing us to push our
storytelling
farther than we could have previously
what's also really powerful about choreo
is that you know if somebody has an idea
they can mock things up really quickly
we gotta show the widowmaker making this
awesome introduction casey was able to
quickly put
a really rough prototype in corio and
philip would come in and on the fly he's
making quick changes they
play tested something that would
normally take weeks it was done
in like a matter of days
each story mission has its own custom
map built for it and these maps are
absolutely
gigantic india is one of our biggest
maps
and it's a fun map because it has a few
story beats that we've taken from
recent comics and and characters in the
game
we've written a history for each city so
that the cities feel
lived in and i think that informs the
artists so that they know
like what it is that the city has been
through gotham very was our chance to
show
torbjorn's workshop we created a space
that kind of fits his height so there's
you know step ladders and
scalable tables we designed the space as
if we were a torpedo
molted steel is pouring out of walls
it's
pretty epic when you walk into it
toronto is under siege by null sector
when the players arrive here there's a
dynamic snowstorm
so as you make your way through the
level the snow is slowly building up
suddenly by the end the characters are
caught in this gigantic snowstorm and
they must fight their way through
in overwatch 2 we want to give you
choice to be able to play this character
or that character
so we're designing a lot of systems
around how their relationships develop
over the course of the story missions in
the campaign
we have a cast of many characters all on
screen
all at the same time and it's fantastic
to actually see them all
interacting and working together in ways
that we've never actually seen
we've always thought about it and hoped
for it but now it's actually happening
it actually requires us to have a whole
new branching dialogue system
if you happen to have genji and mercy in
the second mission of the game you might
get different dialogue
that's about their relationship our
voice actors bring the characters to
life in ways that
everybody has fallen in love with from
inside blizzard to the fans
just to hear this collection of actors
all together
all interacting has been a real treat
i wish people could see how many people
are involved when it comes to something
like telling the story
of overwatch it doesn't just come from a
singular person
it comes from a group and it's a really
talented fun group that all
works together we've been developing
what we hope is one of the best stories
ever
there's some key story moments that i'm
really excited about
i really can't wait to see how people
react to it
we've been talking about the game about
the this universe
i know you all love it so much
right now we can sit down and have a
night of overwatch too
and have it be a really fun experience
and i think
we need some more time so we can say
it's perfectly polished in the way that
we want it
we've made such incredible strides since
we first announced this and showed it to
the community at blizzcon in 2019
the thing that i'm most excited about is
that moment
when we hand the game over to the
players
we want to create something that really
moves people really touches people
that's why we do it we create the game
because we want it to
become part of your life and
for you to experience it
for overwatch 2 we're upping the bar
it's kind of five games in one it's a
huge undertaking
the new tech and the new aesthetics for
the new looks
bring you closer to the characters that
you love and we're just getting started
the fidelity of the gameplay experience
is much richer
we are making cinematics that push the
boundary of what we can do
to tell stories we want this dynamic
world we want things to feel alive
i'm really looking forward to being able
to expand the world of overwatch
for our players we're really trying to
tell
this epic story
in order to make a game great it takes
time
energy collaboration we have just an
incredibly professional
team of designers and artists and
engineers we just love bringing this
world to you guys
so many cool characters it's just a
blast working on it
our goal is for overwatch 2 to be the
worthy
successor to the first game to be the
next evolution and to be a true sequel
we have big plans so thank you for
sticking with us
we're going to cross the finish line and
i know it's going to be awesome
i hope people just end up loving playing
it over and over that's what we want to
try and capture
i'm jumping in i'm playing let's go be
[Music]
heroes
you are not prepared
it has begun
[Music]
today is a special day
we shall stand together
are you with me
[Music]
all right we're gonna watch the video
sent to us
remastered it's the avalator remastered
come on
come on
show it to me
will this be our darkest hour it may
yeah there we go
i knew it was there somewhere somewhere
out there i knew
somewhere out there
yo sick love the campfire
oh that multi shot looks awesome
wow
and console okay
all right that'll be interesting
[Music]
that leaf attack was awesome
oh oh the diaper fight is gorgeous
oh resurrected let's
go come on
[Music]
so that was super exciting uh i'm mr
lomasi i am a twitch streamer i have
been playing diablo 2
for 20 years streaming it for six years
i probably have over 25 000 hours in
this game
and just absolutely love it so
seeing the remaster happen i have to
just
of course ask a very first high level
question why the d3 master right now
well diablo 2 is a very special game to
blizzard as many of you well know
and diablo ii also had its 20th year
anniversary so with that we we really
wanted to
stay true to what that authentic
experience was
for diablo 2 and bring it to the current
audience and
improve it's for the existing audience
and invite new people to
experience it for the first time it's
also good learning opportunities too for
us
especially when we're partnering up with
vicarious visions now to
work on on a remastered projects like
this together so it's been a great
partnership
we've actually worked with blizzard for
a while now um
a couple years even starting with some
battle net integration type things
uh we just finished uh tony hawk
remaster
before that we did crash bandicoot
remasters and it just seemed like a
perfect match for us to work together
it was uh a shock to my to my system to
first to to come in and then see that
it's a remastered trailer
i was not expecting that uh but then to
see the complete
shift um in the design and the art and
everything and i'd really love to hear
more about how you came up with the
process or
what how you want to remaster the look
of it right how you wanted it to
visually
exist and i'd love to bring in chris
amaral to
talk about some of that chris can you
discuss
a little bit of the philosophy and the
design design decisions
around this remaster so luckily we had a
ton of
like good inspiration from the original
d2r
our primary focus is always nostalgia
right we want to make sure we focus on
getting this right
and deliver an authentic experience that
players remembered from 20 years ago
every choice we make with the art with
the models with the environments
should really ignite that nostalgia uh
and then reinforce that emotional
connection
from the original game but then we came
out and came up with like a 70 30 visual
guide
70 is basically the classic this is
where we don't touch
we don't touch what works right you want
to maintain those iconic shapes
colors tones everything should be one to
one and faithful to the original
we want things to feel authentic and
preserve those original designs
with the 30 new like that's kind of like
where we're going to elevate that art
every change we make sure really signify
that step forward visually i also
noticed that the game was
3d and can you talk a little bit about
uh
the discussion or how you moved and some
challenges
moving from 2d to 3d well i mean
evolving from a 2d
sprite game like a 2d image game to a 3d
is very challenging
we basically had to write a complete new
um
pbr renderer so a physically based
renderer on top of
the old game logic it's difficult
because you're dealing with
you know models versus versus 2d sprites
where you have to basically write
you have dynamic lighting you have
dynamic vfx
like a lot of that is uh an additional
system that we have to work out on our
end
so the follow-up to that question i
suppose is i wasn't able to see any
items when i was watching that trailer
are all of the items also going to be
remastered all of the gems all of
every single piece of this and what
sorts of
flavor did you decide to add uh to that
artwork
uh so everything is being redone so we
remodeled everything because everything
has to drop in the game so you have your
you have your
um icon art and then you have your 3d
space
art that flips right so we had to
basically model everything
um so when as far as the inspiration we
actually were inspired by
some original documentation that we
found from you know from blizzard north
where there was a huge you know word doc
of like where the original artists
pulled inspiration from so a lot of that
was like very
like you know historical landmarks
locations and very very much
real world referencing so that was kind
of where we kind of pulled pulled our
inspiration as well we wanted that
that functional design that the original
art had everything felt like it was
believable and that detail really does
help to give it some realistic
context and makes you feel more immersed
in the in the game like it makes you
feel like you're part of this world when
you can see every little buckle and
strap
i remember when we went into the tavern
and there was garlic hanging from
a beam and we're all like what's the
garlic
and then you know this is all full 3d
everything and then
they're like oh yeah there was garlic in
the old game we go back and it's like
four
white sprites and you're like holy cow
yeah garlic and there's
hams hanging and everything so there was
it was really cool to see
like to see it almost for the first time
and it's funny because uh
the original sd like it was made in all
3d so we actually came across a bunch of
screenshots
that were a different camera like it
wasn't the isometric camera it was like
either marketing art or something else
or maybe just exploration
but there was shots of that garlic in
the original
art you just you could never really see
it in the in the in the
in pixel art but it was there so it was
it was
telling that they were they were really
trying to achieve something very
you know very grand with this art i'm
not gonna lie i never knew that they had
garlic hanging in there
i mean maybe maybe a couple white
sprites i thought there were maybe
candles or
who knows no clue but that makes me
excited to go look around now and just
like
explore all of the areas in the game
just to look at the new detail art and
see what well you see it now too because
also we have you know the one new
feature for
for the art on the art side of things is
the zoom camera um
so it you know it'll it'll help you get
in there and look at all the details
like i it was something that i really
felt strongly that like a lot of arpg's
that come out now
all have a zoom feature this will really
get you up and close and personal with
like your armor
your weapons like everything the runes
another way to look at it too
is our legacy toggle feature where you
can flip back
between the old visuals of the game and
our current visuals
it's not even just a simple art swap it
is it is really the old
game running underneath because like
chris was mentioning
our new art engine is our graphics
engine is running on top of the game
um and is mimicking what is running
underneath it's still following all the
same data and rules
and timings of everything so we are
still being true to the
that 25 frames per second of what the
game
is underneath but rendering it in a way
that has more
frames per second yeah i'd love to hear
more about that specifically because
when i go into diablo 2
i'm thinking 25 fps
and like you said the game is built on
that my faster casting my hit recovery
my
all of this stuff is built on 25 fps
so how do you create a game at 60 fps
so all of the logic and and how the game
talks with the server and everything
like that
runs on that cycle and that hasn't
changed
so we still have benchmarks in all of
our content
uh say for animations of when a hit
frame occurs how long it can recover
and all of that that all matches exactly
now it can run at a faster frame rate
and so modern games run on time
not frames so we've done that but all of
the logic still
runs on those same things so you can
wait for your brakes
to occur all of those things still
happen at the exact same
uh and that was through no small effort
but um
but it's super important right because
even if you can't
see it right away you feel it when it's
when it's different
we've done that on lots of areas so for
example the original game only had so
many sprites
to render your rotation so you'd have
your character and they're rendered at
so many angles
and the monsters even less but you could
actually walk
at greater uh directions right you have
i think it was
64 different squares around you that you
would path to and you'd have feet
sliding
we've increased that so now there's more
granularity
obviously it's 3d or character can run
straight but
underneath the hood i mean this is a
game made
back when the inspiration was tabletop
games and so the game is a grid
so it still respects that grid right
like
on the controller will still allow you
to move small amounts
um because you push the stick a little
bit but it's still you're either in a
run state or a walk state stamina is
still a thing you're still on a grid
like all of that logic once again
is all being driven by the old game that
hasn't changed uh
rob was mentioning animation animation
is is also like it was very it was very
challenging because
you know you you only had a few of the
frame
frame counts basically to basically make
that animation so it wasn't like a
modern game where you have
tons of different uh keys to make it
very fluid animation
we had to really like maintain that
timing that pace um
the posing was uh was a big big um
uh focus for us too we wanted to get
those those iconic poses for each
character um and then just align that
silhouette
so continuing the talk of visuals i want
to talk about
characters cosmetics how they look
because i know something that i love
with diablo 2
is just putting on you know a scale male
putting on a full plate male putting on
a sacred armor and seeing the character
like have the different change
and all that but some things still don't
like reflect over
in the color of it or whatnot right some
do some don't is there going to be
changes there or is it just
enhancing all of those visuals and
making them just look even cooler
so our goal was to basically uh be
one-to-one with parity with the original
game so we
we built every piece of armor that was
in the original game and is now
in the remastered version the only
difference we did
is with the icon items so we actually
now we have a
more connected uh visual with the icon
and the item that drops in the game
where before you had you know you had
different visuals
um that's really the only thing we
pushed on as far as modernization
yeah so like shields or weapons a lot of
the unique items that you find in the
game had special kind of icon arts right
and that is something we're actually
going to be showing on your character in
the new visuals
that definitely excites me i think
that's something a lot of people would
love to see you know a lance guard and
have the cool stuff actually on their
character there
it will be the same model you see on
those icons are we going to see
remastering of the cinematics in the
game
yes yes we are yeah full the entire full
28 minutes or whatever is going to be
all remastered
uh with new high fidelity art it's going
to look amazing by the way
so will the sound in those also be
remastered
and any other sound in the game be
remastered all of the audio has been
remastered as well as we've added
additional
um you know surround sound features
there's more ambient there's more
effects going on it's just a richer
experience if you want to play with your
you know full setup however we
have to use that measured hand as well
with audio there's
just a lot of very very iconic sounds
that we really couldn't change right
like if you put a skull
into your inventory that pop noise
don't change my skull sound exactly
right so so yeah so
there are certain things you're gonna
you know you'll hear for like
you you know your your footsteps running
will have some
variety when when the rain kicks in it's
gonna have a lot more depth when you go
to the jungle you'll hear a lot more
life in those you know trees um
but yeah there's just some sounds we
couldn't mess with right with
uh blizzard you know when we're creating
new games one of our
design philosophies is to what we call
find the fun and when we were looking at
d2 again
we very much felt like the fun is still
there so it's actually one of our
core pillars for diablo ii resurrected
specifically was to
keep the fun and keep it at its core and
because of that we're looking at it more
as a remaster at that point and like
what can we do
uh based on what the community wants or
what features naturally are necessary
for
for making this game run on modern day
systems and things like that
i think also on we want to thank and
appreciate the fan base right this is um
this is really a true nod to the
original game
we want to preserve that game and the
structure of that game as much as we can
and if we
went with with the the remake it would
be a completely different game so i
think that was a reason why
we chose this speaking you know from my
experience or first from some of my
communities experience and
the discussions we've had we definitely
felt like
with diablo 2 a remastered just seemed
like the way to go
because there's so many like you said
there's so many of those tiny details
within the game
that create overall when you add them up
create such a big part of the experience
of the game
and remaking that into a new game could
be a challenge and could also
be a challenge in keeping the fun of the
game in that way i kind of look at it a
little bit like
starcraft brood war which also had a
remaster
and how it's like a lot of the pathing
bugs
and the you know duds from the reavers
and all of these things in the game that
were kind of
awful are what make the game beautiful
and what make the game super balanced
and if you were to go and remake it
and remove some of those issues it would
change what the
how the whole entire game plays and so i
felt like with diablo 2
that's kind of the same idea right you
got to keep some of those
difficult details because then it ends
up creating uh
you know the overall experience that we
all know and love yeah we also felt that
like you know for a game during its time
back in 2000 you know based on
limitations or everyone was still
looking at strategy guides or just
limited internet
um it led to that kind of uh typical
game design you see where there was a
lot of mystery discovery
um so we we felt like that was another
part of like you know part of keeping
the fun which was to
maintain that that discovery of the game
as well
so speaking to maintaining
and possibly changing what are the
pieces that
did end up staying the same or if it's
easier to
explain the other way what are the
pieces that were really changed
to bring this remaster to life so at its
core we want it to still be the same
so right away things like
the balance the monsters you see on this
uh spawn rates
item drops and things like that are the
same
and what we're doing is trying to take
any of the rough edges you see
issues resolution issues um
and obviously the art improving the arts
as well
um all these kinds of things you come to
know from a remaster but still
maintaining very much what the game is
so and
when it comes to the features we added
this is probably the biggest
area where we we scrutinize so much is
is this is this addition straying too
much
you know does it still create the same
gameplay experience and other things
like that so
uh things like a shared stash we know
people use mule characters
right and so adding a shared stash we
felt was the right choice
when we have we have a shared stash we
have
oh thank god
now the way that the shared stash works
is there are rules right you can't
you can't have your latter characters
mixing a stash with a non-letter
character
um and you can have your offline
characters
you know can't use your online but for
the most part we're like
people do this anyway with the mule
character so it's okay to give them this
feature
that is like the greatest feature that
you could add
because there's nothing worse than
opening up the game
going in dropping all your gg items to
mule them over because you've run out of
space
and then not being able to log back in
or the game's not created or it didn't
permit time and losing all of your gear
or trying to find someone to help you
transfer your gear over because
oh my gosh a shared stash is
amazing thank you so much that's such a
help
like i said maintain the core was a
thing but the other aspect of it was
to see where we can improve right so the
shared stash is one of them because we
saw it as a very common
concern especially around muelling which
people had workarounds anyway
right so that is one thing another
example is we are reimagining the ui
in the game with a new reimagined ui
we're still trying to stay very faithful
to what you come to expect so you'll
still have the the classic globes on the
hot screen
the skill icons the potion belts and all
that but we are reorganizing a little
bit
you know we're trying to integrate the
menu buttons and the stamina bars closer
together within the hud so it's built a
little bit cleaner and with naturally
with reimagining a ui
we have some liberties to add a few
things so going back to the information
i was talking about
a big thing we're doing on the character
screen is we're adding an advanced stats
screen
as well so we're going to be showing you
all the information
you get from items as well so you don't
have to do that kind of math with like
looking at each of your items and
calculating how much magic find you have
for example it will
be like summarized right there for you
something that we've seen
already in a lot of mods where they've
gone ahead and taken that information
and created a little screen
so that's really nice to see um that you
guys are implementing that as well
because
yeah i don't think anybody likes sitting
sitting down
and counting up the magic find of every
specific
item you know and all of their charms
and all of everything to figure out
what is the number how much do i have
we've also added uh
auto gold so you can opt in
it is a feature you can turn off which
is one of the things we have to be
careful you know a handful of other
things where we're like
if you want this you can turn it on but
you can also keep it off this was
actually something that we started
looking into when we
were adding controller support um
there's a lot of paths that we could
have taken with controller support
um obviously for controllers on console
which we're coming out on
but uh allowing the you know just plug a
controller in
for accessibility reasons for that might
be the way you want to play but it's a
pc first
uh experience like for example there's
you know there's still an inventory grid
there's still inventory tetris
that's core to what diablo 2 is right
taking that away
it starts to become you know something
different and i love that
i think that's the perfect way to really
introduce it because
you're going to have that split in the
community you're gonna have half the
people who say
just give me auto gold it's 20 20. i
don't want to worry about having to pick
up every individual gold stack
but then you're going to have the
opposite side of purists who go
don't touch this like that completely
changes my game experience
and you know if i'm speed running
through the game or playing through
whatever i want to be able to
go over and pick up the gold stacks and
take that time and that's more a part of
the diablo 2 experience for me
i want to jump back to features in a
second
but before we do you just brought up
console play
and i think i feel like we have to jump
into
console the decision for console and
how we're gonna kind of how you're gonna
make that work you already talked a
little bit about like auto gold uh
having that
to be a little more accessible but when
i think of diablo 2 i think of a mouse
going and clicking everywhere how does
this work on a console
say it was to say it wasn't a challenge
would be a bold lie
um so there's a there's a couple things
for the most part
our the game thinks you're still using a
keyboard and mouse with a controller
that was almost a rule we kept
you know um that helped keep us on the
rails
because we didn't want to be sacrificing
once again that
that authentic experience but we did
want to
make it more accessible bring it to a
modern audience i mean there are people
who
were born after this game came out
that we want them to enjoy it and and
play it a lot of those people are used
to
you know just more modern titles that
could use a controller
also from an accessibility of just
allowing you to plug in a controller
um helps for for many other people to
get to enjoy the game
the biggest thing i think that we we are
the two big things we'll say
one is you're changing the way you play
the game
from being kind of an eye in the sky
and telling your hero what to do by
clicking on areas
to actually being your character and
directing them so pathfinding is gone
right because you're doing the
pathfinding and things like that which
creates some very interesting things for
example
the sorceress teleport is meant to
teleport to
to wherever you click so in that area
when you're playing on the console we
will have
a kind of a default distance that you
will teleport to
whereas on the pc you can click wherever
you want
same with barbarian's leap although that
one's interesting because it levels
but it's it's become a very very fun
challenge like
i'm a necromancer and i need to target
an item on the ground that has a certain
keyword
it's working so far but you guys will be
the ultimate judge of that
yeah we've had a lot of talks back and
forth play testing and things like that
um you know a good a big challenge we
had too was categorizing you know all
those 300 character skills
um to see how each of them really played
to see what challenges there were and
yeah like rob mentions that the
necromancer iron golem is a favorite of
ours to
continuously talk about because the
various ways it can target um
also like a sorceress telekinesis is
another example watching the trailer
uh we see the assassin and druid at the
campfire we see a druid casting tornado
i have to ask though uh even still i'm
this includes lord of destruction right
this is going to be a full
encompassing remaster and not just
classic or just a piece
that's correct yeah we are we are going
to be including
both the base diablo 2 and the
expansion lord destruction as well and
we're even
keeping the mode of playing
non-expansion character
as well right so you could still play a
classic
barbarian for example and things like
that okay awesome because that was
something i was also going to ask was
will there be
classic mode because like once again
when you go to the purist
you always have the people that go back
all the way and they're like classic
is pure and that's it and i won't play
anything else yeah it was very much what
we wanted to keep
even based on popularity might not be as
much but it's still a part of the game
and uh it still leads to interesting
ways of playing too right
um a lot of it's even data driven too so
like a lot a lot of the reasons to keep
it were pretty clear to us like
let's let's make sure we're not taking
something away from this remaster
i'd love to go ahead and start talking
about some of the other features or
continue talking about some of the other
features
that you had mentioned before because
hearing each of these
already has gotten me so excited for
this game and so
what are some other little things that
you felt could be changed
wouldn't change the whole flow of the
game but just improve it a little bit
one thing we're looking into is uh
making it easier to interact with
your stash so having quick keys to move
to your stash is is one thing versus
like dragging the mouse to
every time you want to move something to
your stash other things we're looking at
as well
are like an item comparison tool tip so
in case you're looking at some other
item you can you can
hold shift or whatever controller button
is
mapped and then you can see what
equipped items you have just for quick
glances things like that
the item comparison is a great example
of us adding it but added it with a
measured hand
so we don't suggest any gear for anybody
uh the gear in diablo 2 is so
quirky and different and every class can
use everything that us
recommending things like that actually
was more confusing to people
so uh you literally you hold shift and
it's like here's what you got equipped
here's what it is
i think that's the great way to do it
with diablo 2 because i agree i mean
that's
i think that's one of the best parts
about diablo 2. the items are so
fantastic
so unique in their own design that
it would be near impossible to have a
tool tip that can actually recommend
one or the other you know because it's
all so
unique to every situation and character
and skill build and everything
uh we added five more languages so
that's a feature to
a lot of people who speak those other
languages the whole front end is pretty
much
modernized now so your your character is
much bigger front and center right in
the in
in the beginning and you'll have a
backdrop of whatever act you're in
so that's all been streamlined you can
still you know play online or offline
but that flow has been improved
so what are your favorite changes uh
that each of you have
within the game so far uh there's a lot
of
fun it's it's fun to see a lot of the
art come to life with with our new
visuals so
for me one of the things i've been
waiting for since like first starting on
on this game was
to see that character creation campfire
scene
come to life in our in our new arts and
i'm i'm really
happy to see how far it's progressed and
i love seeing that
it's just such an iconic moment it's the
first thing you really see in the game
before you get started
um and it's it's it's amazing can i see
all the art no i'm just kidding
uh so we added like rob said mentioned
we added like an act
specific screen in the front end um and
it's it's basically this
you know large screen we have like a
diorama of each act
and it's just it's amazing to see
because it feels like you're really
there
like you can see the detail you can see
every you know every aspect of the scene
and like
it just has that very immersive feeling
to it so that's probably my favorite
part
i think mine is a little bit more more
squishy the
i think our game has gotten a little
scarier i think that there are certain
areas
in the game where um just the way that
the
you know the the 3d lighting is and the
way the sound is and
i play it on a big screen tv sometimes
and just
it it feels scarier it feels creepier
a little more claustrophobic in you know
certain areas that's not just one
feature there's a lot of things going on
there
um but i think it's really really cool i
would like to hope that it's the
had the original creators had the tools
we have today
it's the experience they would have
wanted to make yeah i think the lighting
really helps with that too because we're
a 3d game
that's one of the biggest differences
between the original games so
what the game had before with the
sprites
um with 3d models built into sprites was
not a a true real-time lighting system
so
because we're pushing that with a 3d uh
graphics engine running on top of the
game and getting actual 3d lighting
inside of those kinds of caverns and
corridors makes for a very
interesting uh experience now because it
just feels more immersive with
with having light react around you like
that yeah i would definitely say
i mean i've only seen the trailer piece
you sent me but even from that
just seeing like down in the tunnels or
the sewers
or you know any of those like like you
said cavern dungeness
zones the lighting it was darker
and brighter and then things like uh the
skeletons with the fire
but it just had like this different i
agree creepier feel
so i haven't seen much more than or
anything more than you guys showed me
but it there was definitely a different
feel to the game
and i loved the fire the most i think
just watching like the sorceress meteor
was like gorgeous fire and lightning
once we got all the effects up and
running
uh that was definitely a couple of times
where we would be just in a review and
we're like oh like and we
10 minutes would go by and we're like oh
crap we had a meeting we were just
playing now
um another thing that that kind of goes
without saying
that just because it's it's it's parody
but
uh a player multiplayer um that just
works but uh
once again it was tricky to get that
going so with multiplayer
are there going to be any changes any
differences
in there from pvp to trading to
how players interact you know units
blocking each other
i mean all sorts of stuff so with
multiplayer uh we want to keep all the
features
you've known and loved there so pvp will
still be there
down to like opening the party window
and engaging hostility
um trading is still going to function
the same as you know
you know you can go into games trade
items or talk in chat channels and
things like that
areas of improvement though like i said
going back to my mentioning of
reimagining a lot of the ui
um improvements to the balance lobby um
so
we're trying to look at some things like
improving uh like how you browse
uh server games like so when you're
looking at a game to join
um and typing passwords and things like
that that's the kind of area we're
trying to see how we could smooth out in
ways like
um making sure you can browse uh normal
games nightmare games and hell games
even though you've graduated to
the the higher difficulty i'm sure
you've known that there's nothing
nothing worse than accidentally killing
bale and nightmare when you're trying to
do nightmare bail runs and you're like
i can't find any of the games anymore
for nightmare bail runs
but you can if you log into a separate
character right you go to a separate
character
and then look at it it's kind of our
logic right we want it we want we saw
since there are workarounds there that
that
made it uh easier for us to make the
decision of allowing some of those
things
um another change is also looking into
uh reducing ladder seasons overall so
right now ladder seasons in diablo 2 are
six months
and we're looking at reducing that as
well to help
have more engagement um and and kind of
drive more incentives too you know six
months is a long time
um and we're looking into like if if we
make it shorter we could probably
have greater beats throughout the year
as well as
seeing people strive harder for getting
like that to that level 99 right
so is there going to be any
reward change on that or will it just
simply be
you know the same standard you get to 99
you're
99 on that leaderboard and i mean that's
a giant reward in itself
but i don't know if there's any uh other
piece go up on the battlenet
website or something we're not looking
into adding any
thing beyond what the game really did
but in some ways there
there will be some things that kind of
come out of because of what we changed
so
we have the latter the leaderboard right
where you can see each class going to
level 99 there are easier ways to filter
through that
um and we're also looking into
saving that right so you can always look
back to previous
uh seasons as well so in a way we're
creating that kind of legacy now
that has kind of been dropped from the
past so that's that's one advantage is
kind of your names could be there in the
legacy if you're looking in the past
i mean i think that would be cool enough
just anything to
keep it there as like uh forever like
this was season one season two you know
like that's when i got my name tonight
because i know a lot of people like to
go and reflect kind of on their old
characters and pushes and
stuff like that character exploration
will not be a thing anymore by the way
due you will not have to worry about
refreshing your character so they will
stay with you
awesome um will there be anything
different with like
character names then if that's the case
oh
yeah so this is one that we talked about
for a very very long time so
uh because we are moving to global
servers
and we have um cross progression
we will allow duplicate names um
because with everyone being in the same
thing across
all consoles and all platforms and other
things like that you would very quickly
bump into duplicates
um like day one and so we are allowing
duplicate names however they will
also be um appended with your
your gamer tag or your battlenet id or
things like that
so that you are still unique um
but this also allows us to get for
people to play the game quicker
because we can give you we can autofill
in your name other things like that
rob touched on a little bit but another
mention there was
going to global servers as well so
this is a new thing we're doing where
the concept
of u.s west u.s east asia regions
um and eu are no longer going to be a
thing
in terms of like um being on separated
servers so now
for the push for a global uh play
with with diablo 2 you can now be able
to join
across people around the world i think
that's a fantastic change that's always
been one of the like saddest parts is
like
they're on eu and i'm on you know us
east and then my other friends on us
west
and it's like how do we get us all
together you know like
okay somebody has to make a sacrifice
there um
and so this is that seems like a really
positive change
so far you guys are killing it i'm
loving all i mean
absolutely i just want to say like i'm
loving all of the changes
and all the decisions that have been
made it feels like you're really
respecting the integrity of the game
but really bringing in a lot of that
quality of life
because diablo 2 just had some of those
pain points like
mule and separate servers and all of
that
um so i just i just want to throw that
out there really quick
there's a lot of yeah love and care
going on into this like
we're very passionate about diablo ii
you know
i can even give you a little anecdotes
of um when i
started on on the team um
i was asking around too naturally as a
designer i want to know as much as
possible about this game
in order to make good decisions on it on
a remaster so
i asked around like uh what what kind of
files and leftover archives do we have
um
from from before from blizzard north and
i was told
i was given some and like this i was
told that was it um which
i quickly disbelieved because i i like
to just
do my own little digging arounds to find
out things so i dug around a lot in
a lot of archives and i looked around in
different teams as well because
naturally a game from 20 years ago
people have moved on different teams and
and like where has data moved around
across our other games across blizzard
so it was it was within folders within
folders i like to say
that i found a lot of
old source files from diablo 2. a lot of
things like within folders of saying
stuff we should archive
and there was a lot of stuff to archive
indeed because there are a lot of things
like we're talking like a
model source files old tools
uh that that blizzard north used to
create like the sprites and things like
that
all these things i i spent months and
months organizing and and
communicate that out to the team and
help getting blizzard library team and
other people to help out too
to help share as much information as
possible which
helps a lot with with when we're
adapting some of these
models and whatnot and making new new
art out of it because you know
sometimes those pixels aren't good
enough and if we have some kind of
source model to look at if we have it
now we can make even closer decisions on
that day when he found that i think that
really helped
like help me greatly like we sent all
that imagery
even the models i think we sent over to
um to the outsource teams and different
art teams
um which they used as like a a stepping
stone
the only only piece of art we actually
reused one to one
um were tyriel's wings so we took this
we actually took material wings from the
old
max file and then just repurpose that
for for hours like we did
very little work very little
modernization of that we just made it
work
um but yeah we did follow a lot of the
rules that um
the old game actually used for like uh
another example is the
uh the succubus the succubus in which i
think the old
the old blizzard north model they reuse
the assassin mesh
for for the body and we do the same
thing we use our assassin mess for the
for the succubus yeah a lot of fun
discoveries that we're actually kind of
making the same decisions on in
interesting ways
another example too like is uh find like
because we found
a lot of stuff uh there's a lot of old
texture files for
some environments on the game so another
example is like the
walls you see in the act ii tombs with
those kinds of like
paintings on them are the same or the
same textures we're using because we
found
the source files for those any symbology
we we have questions on
we always like jump into that archive
try to find some kind of source or
reference or something and
we just reuse it as much as possible we
want this to be as true as as possible
i could even carry over the cinematics
too you know like a lot of the
cinematics cover the same locations
think of like talrash's tomb
with bale in front of it and there's all
those runes going on behind them finding
sources like that to try to match as
much as possible was a goal and
i'm glad to say we did find those kinds
of things and they're matching it very
well so it's helping our cinematics too
there was even concepts we we repurposed
like we found a couple concepts that
were
were amazing from you know 20 years ago
um the blood hawk and the blood hawk
nest
and we use that completely to to rebuild
our new asset
i mean that's fascinating i feel like i
could just sit here for
hours and hours days if you guys talk
through every single thing you found in
the source files
i could too i'm still organizing it to
this day i still
could find something that could work
because i put it i'm very meticulous
with this stuff because i love it so
much you know i'm
i'm putting like categorizing everything
like this is everything i found on war
eve this is everything i found on
on the greater mummy monster or bail or
something and then
if if chris comes to me and needs help
with like some kind of uh
way of identifying what parts of the
creatures are something i even go
through lengths of like seeing if i
could open up those models
um and actually render like re-rendering
them out in a way that we could actually
see
it in higher detail and like you know
see like what like oh the greater mummy
is showing like part of his bone
on his knee so we should try to match
that or something like that and there's
a lot of
interesting stories and references that
we actually used to create the new art
by re-rendering models out to see
everything yeah it was literally like
video game archaeology and even learning
how parts of d1 were made parts of the
code that were commented out
totally geek out on just all of the you
know because it's
it's it's a game that we all kind of
grew up in a lot of us
got into the games industry because of
these types of games and this game
particular right like
yeah and so we it's almost like we're
treating like a classic car
right like okay it probably shouldn't
run on leaded gas anymore
but you really can't change it right you
just got to make it
you know good enough uh even better you
know than they remember and uh
good for another 20 years yeah and even
like you know mention of diablo one is
very key too like
we look at diablo one as well because
naturally this being a sequel to diablo
one
especially within the time span of when
it came like like diablo one you know
was 1996 and diablo 2 2000
a lot of things carried over um
throughout development so
going back to see diablo one and what
it's like also
helped us make decisions even some of
the arts too because like we discovered
certain things we didn't even realize
before
until later down the line like an
example is in the chaos sanctuary
you see a lot of statues um with these
black knights and those are actually
the same chaos knights you see in diablo
one
so like sometimes some of the things i
find even source files from diablo one
were useful
for us for reference so we can make the
new statues and things like that
even the uh the sorcerer and the act
three hireling
shared very similar models like it was
just a
an addition an edition helmet or a
little bit of detail on the chest but
that was really
the difference you guys need to do
a just like developer archaeology
discussion at some point where you just
sit down and talk through all of this
because this is like the most
fascinating stuff i've heard i mean i've
played so much diablo too that i know so
many intricacies
of the game but like when
there's like more to be discovered it's
like oh man i'm like itching to know so
the funny thing is like you know going
back to our like core philosophies on
the game like you know we wanted
to keep discovery and the mystery and
stuff we
because you keep discovering things all
the time when you play diablo 2
like all these little hidden rules and
informations it kind of
it kind of carries that fascination over
through development as well like we find
a lot of things in the code design
documents models things like that that
were really fascinating to see like how
they were made and i i learned something
new every day on the projects
one thing shifting back to the online
play here
i know there's definitely gonna be
questions around security
how are we handling duping how are we
handling bots how are we handling
uh you know just anything around that
round downs and all of the disconnects
and
all of that good stuff that we deal with
online
what's being taken uh or what actions
being taken there
so moving over to modern battlenet helps
us with a lot of those
types of things um to say it's
you know lock tight but i i wouldn't
dare do that that's like throwing a
gauntlet down to the community
um to try to break it but all of that
should be
far more secure now now we do still
allow you to play offline
right um you will need to authenticate
that your copy is legit but after that
um you won't be bothered and so there's
a reason why we leave those
characters quarantined away from online
i mean yeah we have we have a server
team
working on it and these are some of
their efforts right we want to we want
to stop the bots
stop duping as much as possible there's
a lot of strides happening in the back
end of things
so i'm excited to play this game and i'm
sure
a lot of other people are very excited
how can we
sign up for this closed beta and when
will this game be coming out
actually we will be doing a technical
alpha and you can sign up on our webpage
today for future waves of invites as for
the game itself it will be releasing
2021.
well i just want to say thank you uh to
the
remastering team right here i absolutely
am blown away
by how much effort and how much passion
you guys are putting into this game and
and just into diablo 2.
i've loved diablo 2 for 20 years and
i never thought that the game could get
better but
i think you guys are respecting the
integrity while
upgrading and adding and improving and i
think this is going to overall just
better the game so thank you guys so
much i appreciate you having me on
and for all the hard work you've done
awesome thank you i mean your praise
means the world to us i mean you're
you and people like you who keep the
game going um
for for 20 years like that's if you guys
didn't do that
this might not be happening right we see
the passion
um in what you do and what your your
colleagues do
like so thank you even more and thanks
for coming to do this this was fun
[Music]
not even them
[Music]
dolby is a proud partner of blizzcon
online what shock versus the world
in dolby vision and dolby atmos only in
the dolby access app
coca-cola the official refreshment of
blizzcon line
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you